Star Trek and Star Wars are often looked
upon as two sides of the same sci-fi
coin locked in a never-ending Battle of
philosophy versus action that will last
until the end of time or at least until
the arguing nerds need a nap in truth
both franchises probably owe their
continued existence to each other George
Lucas omitted that Star Trek basically
paved the way for Star Wars and William
Shatner conceded that Paramount only
became interested in giving Star Trek a
real shot on the big screen after Star
Wars took the World by storm in 1977.
generally fans pledged outright
allegiance to one franchise over the
other but that's an idea that the
following actors chose to ignore
entirely here are a few actors who
visited both the galaxy far far away and
the alpha quadrant George Takei Star
Trek Legend George Takei have been part
of the Enterprise from the very
beginning first appearing as Lieutenant
Sulu in the original series and going on
to reprise the role for Six Star Trek
feature films video games and even an
episode of Voyager but like many Star
Trek alumni it was through Voice work
that he made the transition between the
two biggest universes in sci-fi the K
became the most high profile name to
take the leap when he landed the part of
General luck derd in the Clone Wars
animated series I congratulate you on
your good fortune when asked about the
pairing in Star Wars it's okay remarks
that he didn't consider it to be jumping
ship telling comic book resources the
Star Trek philosophy is to embrace the
diversity of life and Star Wars is a
part of that diversity Star Trek has
science fiction and Star Wars is more
science fantasy but with the episodes of
Star Wars the Clone Wars that I worked
on I think there is emerging there Star
Trek and Star Wars living together in
harmony
rent Spiner another Legend of track
Brent spinus Runners Lieutenant
Commander Data spanned 15 years that
includes the seven seasons of The Next
Generation and four feature films one of
which earned him a an award for best
supporting actor he also played a data's
brother data's Creator and even made an
appearance in the prequel series
Enterprise as data's great great
grandfather so his place in Trek spans
more than just one series Spina
eventually put Trek behind him at one
point he even publicly took an issue
with fans perception of the show saying
in 2011 we carry guns it's a joke it's
like that illusion that it is somehow
all about peace it's really not
after provoking the wrath of trekkies
everywhere finest subsequent casting in
Star Wars Rebels must have struck a
nerve the actor voiced The Senator gold
Travis a character who coincidentally is
a total traitor no kidding Brent no
foreign
Phillips though he pops up in everything
from girls to Veep to homeboys in outer
space Ethan Phillips most memorable role
Remains nelix the USS Voyager chef and
Ambassador Phillips portrayed the
talaxian for the show's entire
seventh-season run but he also made
three minor appearances as different
Star Trek characters in next generation
and Enterprise Philips played two
different Ferengi and he also made a
cameo appearance in Star Trek first
Contact as a holographic metro d
Phillips has since become something of a
regular in the world of Star Wars video
games providing the voice of Transport
Pilots ham and flat in Force Commander
he also played an imperial medical Droid
kranti and governor and the Royal
grenade Trooper in 2002's Galactic
Battlegrounds as well as several
additional characters in 2003's Knights
of the Old Republic hello hello to you
you're new to the academy aren't you
Simon Pegg British actor Simon Pegg is
known for many roles from his zombie
fighting hero in Shaun of the Dead to
his recurring role in The Mission
Impossible film franchise but track fans
know him as Montgomery Scots in JJ Abram
Star Trek reboot movies he proved to be
such an asset to Abrams but the director
later admitted he had an ulterior motive
when he cast him in the minor role of
Encore floods in Star Wars the Force
awakens saying when we were shooting the
force awakened in Abu Dhabi he was there
as an actor but for me he was there as a
writer and filmmaker and as someone to
go around the issues I was having at the
time with the story and to get some
great feedback it probably didn't take
much for Abram to convince Peg to appear
in the film either Star Wars
I burned the Star Wars Peg's input
didn't end there either he was also
sought out by Paramount bosses when
Abrams left a Star Trek franchise
bringing Peg on board as a co-writer for
the third installment Star Trek Beyond
Ron Perlman best known for playing the
Demonic anti-hero Hellboy as well as his
starring role on Sons of Anarchy and a
few hundred voice roles Ron Perlman has
been around the block more than once
many of Pullman's hundreds of credits
lie in genre films an area of Cinema
he's always supported so when the
opportunity came along to join the cast
of 2002 Star Trek Nemesis as a Riemann
vicerai permanent asked his manager for
the time and place while he enjoyed
working on the movie neither audiences
nor critics seem to share his enthusiasm
fortunately his foray into Star Wars
received a much more positive reaction
permanent voiced garnacht a transition
scavenger who meets his untimely end at
the hands of General Grievous in the
highly acclaimed first season of The
Clone Wars Ed Begley Jr veteran actor
and environmentalist at Begley Jr is
probably best known for its seven year
stint on Saint elsewhere though he
actually has hundreds of TV and movie
credits to his name among them are his
appearance on the Star Trek Voyager
two-parter Futures End in which he took
on the one-off role of 20th century
industrialist Henry Starling who just
happens to be working with a character
played by Sarah Silverman Begley Jr has
since said he felt really blessed to be
a part of the Star Trek franchise as a
huge fan of the show though that didn't
stop him from taking a gig with the
Rival franchise the very same year he
was hired to provide the voice of Boba
Fett in the radio adaptation of Return
of the Jedi produced with the blessing
of George Lucas and speaking of Boba
Fett's Jason wingreen a victim of the
dreaded Star Wars DVD editions Jason
wingreen saw his part as the voice of
Boba Fett in The Empire Strikes Back
chopped under a place with the voice of
tamura Morrison the man who played Jango
Fett in the prequel trilogy to add
insult to injury when green was never
actually credited for his contribution
to the Star Wars Universe which only
became common knowledge four years after
the great remastering of o4 while he may
be best remembered as Harry Snowden from
All in the Family her Star Trek fans
he'll always be Dr linke the Federation
scientist who gets sent to the
uninhabited Planet Manara 2 to conduct
studies in original series episode The
empath
beep Roy the diminutive Deep Roy has an
impressive filmography stretching back
about 40 years including two big screen
Star Wars installments Roy played a
musician trophy MC cool in Return of the
Jedi a member of the max Rebo Band the
12 piece Ensemble that performs in Jabba
the Hutt's Tatooine Palace the four foot
three actor actually appeared and
credited in The Empire Strikes Back as a
body double for Yoda during a number of
scenes on Vega bar Roy is also one of
the very few actors to appear on screen
in both franchises playing Scotty's
oyster-faced alien sidekick Keen sir in
the rebooted Trek series kinsa was never
even meant to join Scotty on the
franchise's most famous Starship but
Roy's performance was so memorable that
they invited him back to reprise his
role Clancy Brown sci-fi fans shouldn't
really need an introduction to Clancy
Brown he's played The Immortal
antagonist the kurgan in Highlander
mom
and Sergeant Zim and Starship Troopers
even your kids know Clancy Brown if only
in voice donate to the children's fun
why wouldn't children ever done for me
despite an impressive sci-fi resume it
wasn't until 2002 that brown showed up
on Star Trek taking on the role of
zebral in the Enterprise episode desert
Crossing in it Archer and sucker accept
an invitation to his Homeworld and
unwittingly find themselves caught up in
a war among his countless voice roles
Brown also dipped into Star Wars
territory when he played Darth Maul's
brother Savage oprus in the Clone Wars
series as well as Ryder Azadi in Rebels
who only kind of looks exactly like him
renowned stage actor Clive Revel
portrayed a tweaked version of classic
English character sir guy of Gisborne in
1991's Next Generation episode Cupid
which took the crew to the 12th century
world of Robin Hood while it wasn't the
most memorable performance the New
Zealand native had given over the course
of his distinguished career at least it
wasn't replaced in later edits like his
work on the original Star Wars Trilogy
was
foreign
sorry Revel supplied the voice of
Emperor Palpatine in the first cut of
The Empire Strikes Back birds like so
many others his work was dubbed over for
the 2004 DVD release replaced with the
voice of Ian McDermott who took over as
the emperor with Return of the Jedi
Revel was humble about the change
however conceding that continuity was
important and the saying that the
filmmakers made a good choice with
McDermott considering that the original
1980 Emperor was played by a woman with
superimposed chimpais pretty much
anything was an improvement Craig
grunberg as a self-proclaimed geek Greg
grunberg couldn't have asked for a
better friend than a man who rebooted
Star Trek and kick-started the third
Star Wars Trilogy Greenberg has worked
with JJ Abrams almost exclusively so
when Abrams began his cinematical
invention of Star Trek he called on
grumberg again drafting his friend to
overdub the dialogue for James Kirk's
stepdad hey are you at your mind that
car is an antique if you can get away
with this just cause your mother Planet
you get your ass back home now he
appeared in person as Commander Finnegan
in 2016 Star Trek Beyond though by that
point he had already crossed the
franchise divide Bromberg played
resistance Pilots to Upper wexley in
2015's the force awakens though he later
told star trek.com that he's on the
fence about which franchise is his
favorite Olivia d'abo
[Music]
it's known to trekkies a Starfleet
Academy in CERN Amanda Rogers from the
Next Generation episode True Q Olivia
Darbo is probably best known for playing
Kevin Arnold's hippie's sister Karen in
The Wonder Years believeth or not Darbo
considers herself to be a pretty big
sci-fi nerd telling the official Star
Trek website I considered it a real
honor to be working on the continuation
of the Star Trek Legacy I'd grown up
with it had a huge effect on my
childhood and nothing like Star Wars it
made me more curious about space other
life forms in our galaxy and The Wonder
of astronomy in general in 2008 she
joined a number of her former Star Trek
colleagues at lucasfilm to record the
voice of luminara and Julie for the
Clone Wars animated series and oh yeah
party Maloney emerging from The Darkest
Day in Star Wars history is Patty
Maloney who played a part in the
infamous and totally bizarre Star Wars
holiday special the 3 foot 11 actress
was hired to play the special's main
character Chewbacca's son lumpawaro
better known as lumpy no seriously
[Music]
Maloney's memories of the especially
weird program were completely positive
saying we were all very pleased with the
outcome of it actually I was I was very
pleased with it the special ed in 1978
and because of the sheer shame involved
was never seen again in any official
capacity Maloney's role in Star Trek was
another one created for a person of a
stature in the 1996 Voyager episode the
Thor she plays one of the many creations
of the clown a manifestation of fear
born of a linked to neural network
because you know sci-fi this time he's
credited as only little woman we're just
still a huge improvement over being a
grunting idiot named lumpy added bonus
was even a speaking role oh boy and you
got to hang out with Michael McKean
Point Star Trek
[Laughter]
okay we're taking that point back
Star Trek Beyond is a fun fast-paced
space romp but just like any great
action movie these days it still
includes more than a few head scratchers
here's a look at some dumb things in
Star Trek Beyond everyone just ignored
random chance
Creepy Bad Guy crawl is looking for an
alien artifact that was chucked into
space hundreds of years ago so how
convenient is it that Kurt happens to
randomly end up with it after a totally
unrelated diplomatic Mission it's also
handy for crawl that Kirk kept it on
board his ship instead of sending it
somewhere safe
oh and the fact that he brings it to the
closest possible Outpost to crawl's base
is a pretty lucky break as well you know
considering the endless vastness of
space and all
dangling plot thread when everyone takes
the Escape pods and heads for cross
Planet Scotty drops out late navigates
this pod down to the surface when he
gets there he realizes he's landed it on
the edge of a very big cliff and finds
himself in a classic Fast and Furious
style action scene where he has to run
up the falling pod and grab hold of a
tiny ledge hanging off the cliff then we
cut away and the next time we see Scotty
he's safely wandering around the planet
at the bottom of the cliff so how did he
get off the cliff Scotty is known for
his big brain but not for his epic
mountain climbing skills unless he jury
rigged the jet pack we'd expect the
scene to end with him just falling to
his death
those darn drones it's a cross whole
thing to get this artifact is to create
a deadly bio weapon but since crawl
already has a seemingly Unstoppable
drone Army capable of taking out
starfleet's most advanced ships why not
just attack with that style points plus
we find out those drones are based on
some ancient mining Tech left on the
planet so how to crawl turn a bunch of
mining robots into the universe's most
dangerous Fleet does that mean some
jerky super villain will just be able to
weaponize all the drones we have flying
around here on Earth this amazing
Innovation then lowers itself slowly to
the ground drops off the package and
flies straight back up to altitude
did we just figure out the real reason
that Amazon's Jeff Bezos made a cameo in
the movie
cheers
total recrawl Jayla has conveniently
been living in the USS Franklin for
years and has used a fancy bit of
cloaking Tech to keep the ship hidden
from crawling his minions but once crawl
is revealed to be the long-lost captain
of the Franklin it begs the question how
did he not already know where his ship
landed
space Amnesia along that a drinking
space beers yeah it's probably the space
beers that's usually it
foreign
Beastie bikes
let's make some noise
okay so No One's Gonna dispute that this
was probably one of the most fun scenes
in the movie and yes we love the BC boys
too but even though it's been a running
gag since 2009 Star Trek reboot the fact
that the Beastie Boys are still
supposedly relevant three centuries from
now is actually pretty silly don't agree
here's a quick quiz name a pop star from
the 1760s
while you're Googling that we also have
to ask about the motorcycle that plays a
pivotal role in the finale why is there
an ancient motorcycle on the USS
Franklin and how is it still working
after all this time between the bike and
the Beastie Boys it seems like director
Justin Lynn really just wanted to make a
cool 80s biker flick instead
Uhura spidey sense we get a peek at the
USS Franklin's old crew footage Midway
through the film though Kirk and
everyone else turns away before Idris
Elba appears in the frame but Uhura
circles back to the footage late in the
film gets a look at the long lost
captain and immediately deduces that the
captain is actually crawl
[Music]
it's him
but how he doesn't look anything like
that anymore does she have facial
recognition software along with a GPS
tracker and that necklace spot gave her
Lieutenant wears a vokaya amulet which I
presented to her as a token of my
affection and respect
you gave your girlfriend radioactive
jewelry the emission is harmless doctor
but its unique signature makes it very
easy to identify
you gave your girlfriend a tracking
device
that was not my intention or maybe all
that Vulcan radiation gave her
superpowers that let her see through
Hollywood prosthetics
terrible security
when crawl makes his move and attacks
Yorktown pretty much the only people
around to help stop the Baddie from
unleashing his virus are Kirk and the
members of his team along with of course
Greg grumberg but this is supposed to be
a fully manned top of the line space
station so why are there no actual
security measures the only time we see
anyone at all is when the Yorktown Mall
Cops run right past the bad guy like a
bunch of well Mall Cops
good job
the big questions
a big chunk of crawl's plan is built on
the fact that he's able to hack into
Starfleet and figure out where the
artifact is to Stage his attack on the
Enterprise so if he can contact
Starfleet why didn't he ever just like
call them for help isn't he like a few
hundred years old how does he even know
how to pull any of this off how is crawl
able to hack into Starfleet at all is he
a member of anonymous
Scotty wrote the script now it's
important when considering some of the
goofier aspects of Star Trek Beyond to
remember that Simon Pegg co-wrote the
script that's probably why Scotty can
suddenly scale sheer Cliffs Finds a Hot
Space elf girlfriend right out of the
Hobbit and then somehow manages to get
the USS Franklin running again in a
matter of hours more than a century
after a crashed face first into a planet
knowing that Scotty is basically a
walking deus ex machina also explains
how he was able to teleport 20 people at
a time during the film's Epic escape
sequence just a few minutes earlier he
didn't trust it enough to beam out two
people at a time which is why bones
nearly got nabbed by crawls thugs at
least I won't die alone
[Music]
hello
well that's just typical but when the
plot needs it suddenly he's totally cool
with just transporting entire football
teams with no problems sure
how many people can the Franklin
transport at a time uh with a wee bit
modification 20 Max but I'm not sure how
long it would hold out oh and then
there's the part where they jump start
the Franklin just by flinging it off a
mountain despite the fact that we're
told the Franklin wasn't designed to
even function in the planet's atmosphere
of course it's no surprise that he
struggled riding the 13th Star Trek film
it's a fact she was a day for his Knight
shows eggs sure as every old numbered
Star Trek movie
hmm
Star Trek voyager's take on the Star
Trek universe existed on screen for
seven seasons and along the way there
was a lot more happening behind the
scenes than you know from the show's
impressive impact to some crazy drama
between actors here's the Untold Truth
of Star Trek Voyager
Paramount used Star Trek Voyager to help
launch its new Mini Network United
Paramount Network or UPN in January
1995. UPN only had a few shows when it
launched and only aired on Monday and
Tuesday nights between 8 pm and 10 p.m
that same month Voyager was joined by
the sitcom picksteye comedian Richard
Ginny's platypus man the Richard Grieco
action drama marker and the Sci-Fi
western series Legend voyager's
caretaker was upn's first telecast on
January 16 1995 and 21.3 million viewers
tuned in of the Network's 5 launch
series Voyager was the only program to
survive its first year yes believe it or
not even a winner like platypus man got
the ax Voyager went on to outlive other
early UPN series like the Sentinel the
Sci-Fi drama Nowhere Man and the hit
teen sitcom Moesha Voyager was also the
only early UPN series to last seven
seasons
when it came time to cast Captain
Janeway voyager's casting team looked at
a lot of actresses among the candidates
was Linda Hamilton of the Terminator
films Susan Gibney who played the
recurring role of Dr Leah Brahms on Star
Trek the Next Generation and Buck Rogers
Alum Aaron gray despite the competition
the role eventually went to Canadian
actress Genevieve bujol however bujol
didn't last long quitting just a day and
a half into production Voyager
co-creator Rick Berman said of bujol's
departure this was a woman who in no way
was going to be able to deal with the
rigors of episodic television
documentaries like what we left behind
and the captains include cast and crew
talking about 16-hour work days so it's
tough to blame bujol too much for
abandoning ship Kate Mulgrew was then
cast in the role she'd keep for the
show's run do you like the Ferengi I do
like it very much the Ferengi that one
that's a Ferengi
Star Trek has helped launch plenty of
acting careers and Voyager gave an early
role to someone known today for
Blockbuster action flicks Dwayne The
Rock Johnson still mostly known as a WWF
wrestler in those days made one of his
first non-wrestling television
appearances in the Voyager season 6
episode sunkatsa while the rest of the
crew is enjoying Shore leave Tim Russ's
tuvak and Jerry Ryan seven of nine take
a shuttle to examine a nearby nebula on
the way they're attacked and captured by
aliens running a popular fighting arena
tuvak is badly injured and the Arena's
owner uses the injured Vulcan as
leverage to make seven fight for him her
first opponent is The Rock who plays an
unnamed pindari champion in a fun fourth
wall breaking Moment The Rock gives his
signature eyebrow race to the crowd
before defeating seven in the ring most
Trek fans have their own pick for their
favorite Trek series so if a Trek fan
ever tells you that everyone loves or
hates one series or other never believe
them we're not trying to tell you
Voyager is the best Star Trek show but
some numbers have revealed something
interesting about the series enduring
popularity in 2017 Netflix reviewed data
from over 100 million subscribers in
almost 200 countries to figure which
episodes of Star Trek were watched the
most at the time Netflix carried all the
franchises series produced between Star
Trek the Original Series and the 2005
finale of Star Trek Enterprise Netflix
didn't count first or second episodes
because those generally have more views
than others Voyager and the Next
Generation were the only two series with
episodes in the top 10 most watched and
of those 10 episodes 6 belong to Voyager
those six episodes helped to prove the
lasting popularity of both the Borg and
Voyager season 4 newcomer seven of nine
most of the six episodes are very seven
and Borg Centric they include the series
finale endgame the two-part Scorpion and
dark Frontiers and the gift which is the
episode immediately following Seven's
first appearance
behind the scenes moguru resented the
addition of seven of nine whose good
looks helped boost voyager's ratings on
2013's girl on guy podcast Ryan talked
about feeling physically ill at the
thought of doing scenes with a
particular Voyager co-star she didn't
name Mo group but she mentioned details
making it clear it could be none other
while researching his book The 50-year
Mission co-writer Ed Gross looked into
the feud and got more answers than he
expected one unnamed cast member claimed
Mulgrew tried to enforce a rule that
Ryan wouldn't be allowed to use the
bathroom during work because it took too
long to get her in and out of costume
Harry Kim actor Garrett Wang said
mulgrew's anger wasn't initially
directed toward Ryan but once it was the
effect on set was awful chicote actor
Robert Beltran told gross if it was me
being insulted and Kate was a man I
probably would have taken a swipe at the
guy to her credit the Voyager Captain
owned up to her behavior toward Ryan
Mulgrew told gross this is on me not
Jerry Ryan I'd hoped against hope that
Janeway would be sufficient that we
didn't have to bring a beautiful sexy
girl in
one of the more prominent recurring
characters on Voyager was Ensign
Samantha Wildman played by Nancy Hower
voyager's Unexpected Journey to the
Delta quadrant separated the pregnant
insign wild men from her husband by
about 70 000 light years on the bright
side her half-alien daughter Naomi
eventually turned into another Voyager
fan favorite becoming close friends with
Ethan Phillips neelix and even the
emotionally aloof seven of nine
interestingly Samantha Wildman's name
has a special meaning Wildman first
appeared in the second season episode
elogium co-written by Jimmy Diggs the
same year he sold the script digg's wife
almost died a kidney transplant saved
her life and Diggs learned the donor was
a seven-year-old girl named Samantha he
wrote a letter to voyager's producers
asking them to name the episode's new
character Samantha
congratulations Samantha
Diggs wrote the ancient Greeks believed
the gods would reward heroic Mortals by
placing them in the stars by honoring
the memory of this child the producers
of Star Trek will accomplish the same
thing one of the more popular characters
on Voyager was also its best source of
comic relief the doctor played by Robert
picardo the doctor is an emergency
medical hologram meant only for
short-term use but his job gets much
more involved when voyager's human
doctor dies after the ship is thrown
into the Delta quadrant speaking to star
trek.com in January 2020 picardo
explained a special spontaneous moment
from his audition after reading the last
scripted line I believe someone has
failed to terminate my program picardo
improvised with I'm a doctor not a
nightlight picardo said the line yielded
big laughs on set what makes the ad-lib
line funny is its similarity to lines
from Dr Leonard bones McCoy from Star
Trek's original run actor DeForest Kelly
frequently delivered variations of I'm a
doctor NADA but picardo apparently had
no idea he said I faked my way through
the audition and ad-libbed a DeForest
Kelly joke without knowing it was a
DeForest Kelly joke
Tim Ross actually had a few Trek one-off
gigs before landing the role of security
chief tuvak on Voyager on Deep Space
Nine he's a Klingon mercenary who helps
take the station hostage in the episode
invasive procedures in the next
Generation Starship Mine he's one of a
group of criminals trying to steal
trilithium resin from the Enterprise in
1994's Star Trek generations Russ plays
a lieutenant on the bridge of the
Enterprise B in the film's opening but
before he did any of that work he
auditioned for the part of Geordi
laforge on the Next Generation speaking
to trekmovie.com in 2018 Russ said that
he was ultimately relieved to have lost
the Geordie role to Levar Burton why the
dialogue bruss explained the role of
tuvak was somewhat more organic and much
easier in terms of dialogue I am glad I
didn't get stuck with all that
engineering Tech talk that kind of
dialogue doesn't do anything for me Russ
also had the distinction of getting to
appear in one of the few episodes in
which Voyager characters could cross
over into other series Tuvok shows up in
the Deep Space Nine episode Through the
Looking Glass though it's not quite the
same tubak the episode takes place in
the Mirror Universe first made famous by
Star Trek the Original Series Mirror
Mirror this tubak appears as a member of
the Terran resistance fighting against
the Klingon cardassian Alliance
one of voyager's recurring characters
was Ensign voric played by Alexander
enberg voric is a Vulcan engineer who
often worked closely with Milana Torres
played by Roxanne Dawson boric develops
a romantic interest in balana with
violent consequences and perhaps
vorick's most memorable appearance the
season 3 episode Blood Fever voric
experiences the Vulcan mating period and
chooses bolana as his mate he forms a
telepathic connection with balana
causing her violent Klingon mating
instincts to emerge the situation ends
in a duel between bilana and voric which
both thankfully survived between 1997
and 2001 enberg appeared in Nine
episodes of Voyager as voric but it
wasn't the first time he appeared in a
trek show or even the first time he
appeared as a Vulcan enberg was cast as
a Vulcan named tauric in the lower decks
an episode in the middle of the next
generation's final season focusing on
the Enterprise's Rank and file with
enberg not only playing Vulcans on both
shows but with both characters sharing
rhyming names some fans have wondered if
there could be a connection between
voric and toric according to Voyager
co-creator Jerry Taylor who also happens
to be enberg's mother there could be in
the 2012 book Star Trek the Next
Generation 365 Taylor implies toric and
voric may very well be twin brothers and
since she's their mother we guess she
would know
as voyager's first officer Commander
chicote is often forced to tell Captain
Janeway thing she doesn't want to hear
fittingly actor Robert Beltran was known
for speaking his mind on what he likes
and doesn't like about Voyager
regardless of the consequences by 2000
Beltran had aired enough dirty laundry
in public that producer Kenneth biller
told sfx magazine that he thought the
actor quote should stop whining and do
his job speaking to star trek.com in
2012 Beltran talked about not feeling
fulfilled on Voyager he complained
you're doing the same thing every week
with a new variation I didn't like some
of the things that were going towards
the last three years and I risked being
fired because I wasn't happy creatively
according to Beltran chicote didn't have
a lot of interesting relationships after
the departure of Martha hackett's cesca
his former lover who's eventually
revealed to be a cardassian Beltran
revealed after cesca left it was only
that relationship with the captain that
had death to it chicote and the other
characters there wasn't much of a
relationship there and Beltran has one
problem with Trek that a lot of fans
might consider downright heresy Beltran
hates the prime directive the Starfleet
principle that forbids interference in
Alien Civilizations for any reason in
2012 he told CNET the idea of leaving
any species to die in its own filth when
you have the ability to help them it's a
bunch of fascist crap
years after the series run it can be
easy to forget how important it was in
1995 for a woman to be leading a Star
Trek series today we're growing
accustomed to female-led action films
and series including Star Wars epics and
superhero Blockbusters but in the mid
90s it was still a big deal especially
in science fiction Mulgrew left an
important mark on our culture and it's
felt far beyond the world of Television
speaking to Trek movie in 2019 about the
25th anniversary of Voyager Mulgrew was
asked about highly visible female
politicians like Stacy Abrams and
Alexandria ocasio-cortez hoot named
Captain Janeway as an early influence
Mulgrew said she made a surprise
appearance at one of ocasio-cortez's
rallies and that when they announced
Mulgrew ocasio-cortez gasped she turned
and when I approached her I think she
kind of fell Mulgrew said ocasio-cortez
related stories of watching Voyager as a
child and that when they lost their
screen they had bad reception in their
house and often the television was just
black and white she'd listened to it
like a radio show
with 10 series and over 700 episodes
it's only natural that Star Trek has
messed up a few times over the years
whether they're continuity errors
editing blunders wardrobes grow-ups or
other oversights here are some of the
biggest on-screen mistakes you'll find
in Star Trek TV shows
23rd Century con man hairy Mudd is one
of the first recurring villains in Star
Trek the Original Series
season 1 episode muds women mud beams
aboard the Enterprise accompanied by a
trio of women whose Beauty leaves both
Scotty and McCoy dumbstruck Dr McCoy's
arousal isn't The Only Thing Worth
noticing about his appearance in this
scene when he first sees the women McCoy
is wearing his Bridge uniform which
includes a light blue shirt with a dark
blue collar the camera cuts to mud's
alluring ladies and when it returns to
McCoy he's wearing the medical Smock he
usually reserves for Sick Bay Duty there
are also Windows behind him indicating
he's in a completely different part of
the ship the next time we see McCoy he's
back in the transporter room wearing his
Bridge uniform apparently whoever edited
mud's women didn't think McCoy looked
aroused enough so they used archival
footage of him without caring about
where he was or what he was wearing
either that or the space-time Continuum
was acting really weird that day
one of the more interesting season one
episodes of Star Trek Deep Space Nine is
dramatist personae in which a contagion
renders the entire crew power hungry and
violent except for Constable Odo the
crew soon splits into warring factions
and after Commander Cisco survives a
botched assassination attempt he tries
to escape the station with Chief O'Brien
one of the first things they do is throw
away their Starfleet Communicator badges
so that no one can track them as the
only member of the Senior Crew who isn't
losing his mind Odo manages to
manipulate both parties into a cargo bay
where he can blast the contagion into
the void of space Odo warns everyone to
hold on to something before opening the
bay door and Cisco still without a comb
badge grabs a cargo container we then
see several shots of different crew
members fighting the pull of the vact
once Odo closes the door the camera
turns to Cisco whose comb badge has
inexplicably reappeared on his uniform
why
I have no idea you could try to explain
this by saying that the com badges
return symbolizes Cisco's return to
sanity but otherwise it's an obvious
goof
yesterday's Enterprise is one of the
most beloved episodes of Star Trek the
Next Generation the story changes the
Trek timeline with Wharf absent from the
Enterprise Tasha Yar still alive and the
Federation stuck in a losing war with
the Klingons among other changes the
Enterprise's interior is a lot darker
and the cruise uniforms have changed
so right
it's changed the timeline is restored
thanks to the intervention of the
enigmatic gynin who senses something is
wrong and convinces Captain Picard to
help restore their reality yesterday's
Enterprise ends with geinen and Jordy
talking in 10 forward geinen asks the
chief engineer to tell her about Tasha
Yar someone she never met in the
original timeline but for some reason
Jordy is still wearing his uniform from
the alternate Enterprise we know this
because of the black cuffs on his
sleeves which aren't a feature of his
normal uniform unless this is a subtle
hint that gynin never really succeeded
in fixing the timeline someone should
have told Jordy he was in the wrong Duds
seriously
a lot of things change on Star Trek
Voyager after the introduction of the
reformed Borg crew member seven of nine
because of her issues with trust and
isolation seven is rarely seen
fraternizing with voyager's crew instead
we usually find her working alone in the
astrometrics lab unfortunately the
increased role of the astrometrics lab
leads to a bit of confusion in season
7's shattered Commander chicote finds
himself thrown back in time to an
earlier version of Voyager when he tells
Captain Janeway that they need to get to
the astrometrics lab she responds that
Voyager doesn't have one implying it
hasn't been built yet Voyager doesn't
have an astrometrics lab but this isn't
the case while we never see the
astrometrics lab before seven comes on
board it was always a part of the ship
in season 4's revulsion chicote orders
Kim in seven to update the lab because
it hasn't been upgraded since before the
events of the series premiere how could
it have been upgraded if it didn't exist
it's a long story one of the most unique
episodes of Star Trek Enterprise is
season two's carbon Creek a huge chunk
of it doesn't even feature the regular
cast Jolene Blalock does double duty
playing both the Vulcan first officer to
Paul and to Paul's ancestor Tamir to
Paul tells the story of how a small
group of Vulcans including Tamir crashed
in the United States in the 1950s and
were forced to pose as humans
would you like to hear the story Tamir
initially tries to keep her distance
from the earthlings around her but
eventually finds herself becoming
sympathetic to them and even involved in
their lives just as Scotty sells the
secret of transparent aluminum in Star
Trek 4 the Voyage Home Tamir takes a
trip to Pittsburgh in 1957 and sells the
secret of Velcro so she can help a human
boy pay for his college tuition the only
problem with this detail is that not
only did someone else invent velcro but
it was patented in 1952 and was already
in use in the United States by 1957.
obviously 50s kids weren't securing
their sneakers with it yet but it was
still out there do you realize you've
just Rewritten our history books
father-son relationships are a major
theme in DS9 usually represented by the
love between Ben Cisco and his son Jake
but in a season 4 two-parter that
relationship expands to include Ben's
Father Joseph Cisco we meet the stubborn
but charismatic restaurant owner when
Ben is summoned to Earth to brief
Starfleet on the growing threat of the
Dominion the only problem is that
earlier in the series we're led to
believe Joseph Cisco is dead Ben never
outright says he's deceased but all the
statements he makes about his father
before season 4 strongly imply he's
already passed on for example in both
the series premiere and season 2's
Paradise Ben refers to his father in the
past tense he says Whoa my father was a
chef also in season two's the alternate
Ben tells Odo of an illness his father
suffered strongly implying he died from
it DS9 never provides an explanation for
this discrepancy but regardless Joseph
is a beloved character who continued to
appear in the series regularly and were
glad that he was around to see it
through
you up for a stroll with your old man
I can't think of anything I'd rather do
written by the acclaimed science fiction
author Harlan Ellison the city on the
edge of forever is often considered one
of the best episodes of any Star Trek
series as well as one of the saddest
episodes in the franchise but even here
there's a blink and you'll miss it error
that could take you out of the story
pretty fast the story transports McCoy
Spock and Captain Kirk back in time to
the Great Depression kirkensbox search
for McCoy Whose actions they fear have
deeply harmed the timeline the pair
secure an apartment as their base of
operations and it's this apartment
building that provides the episode with
its goof we have a flop remember what
Captain a place to sleep after a scene
in which a homeless man accidentally
vaporizes himself with McCoy's phaser
the camera cuts to the exterior of
kirkenspock's building on the right side
of the building you can clearly see a
yellow sign indicating that the
structure contains a bomb shelter in
case of nuclear attack such signs didn't
exist until the 1960s at which point the
Great Depression had been over for
decades
very strange
season 4 of DS9 brings an old friend
back to Trek TV in the season 4 premiere
the way of the warrior the Klingon Wharf
is sent to the space station on special
assignment and by the end of the episode
he's a member of Captain Cisco's senior
staff but along the way Wharf makes at
least one statement that doesn't hold up
to scrutiny
I am not interested in your conclusions
aboard the defiant Cisco orders the
ship's cloaking device on loan from the
romulans to be activated Wharf seems
uneasy and when Cisco asks him why the
Klingon responds
it is just
I have never been on a federation
Starship that had a cloaking device it
is
a little strange the thing is this isn't
actually the first time Worf's been
aboard a federation ship with a cloaking
device toward the end of the TNG season
7 episode the Pegasus the Enterprise
uses a salvaged Romulan cloaking device
and Warf is on the bridge when it
happens you could argue that the
Enterprise is only briefly cloaked in
the Pegasus and he forgets about it but
Wharf is a pretty detail-oriented guy he
doesn't forget his Klingon operas and he
wouldn't forget being cloaked on the
Enterprise
in tngs the host the trill Diplomat Odon
is badly entered and the Enterprise crew
discovers a slug-like creature living
inside him with whom he shares a
symbiotic relationship the symbiotic
trills would later appear more
prominently in DS9 in the form of main
characters jetsia Dax and esri Dax
however there are huge discrepancies
between what we learn about the trill in
the host and what we see in DS9 in the
host Odon has prominent forehead riches
while later trills have smooth foreheads
and leopard spots along their sides both
Odon and Dr Crusher say that using
Transporters is dangerous to Trill
symbians but Jadzia and esri use
Transporters without issue in the host
the symbian's presence is a complete
surprise to the Enterprise crew it's
just that they kept their inner worm
creatures private but in DS9 we learned
the trill have been part of the
Federation for a long time and the
existence of their symbians is common
knowledge it has always been this way
finally there's the relationship between
host and symbiant in DS9 it's made clear
that the personality of what's called a
joined Trill is a mix between the minds
of the host and the Symbian while in the
host only the symbians personality
exists Odon claims to be the same person
both when he inhabits the body of Riker
and when he later appears in a woman's
body I will never forget you
one of the best recurring bad guys on
TNG is data's evil twin lore who shares
data's abilities coupled with Twisted
emotions and a total lack of empathy for
other living beings we first meet him in
season 1's data lore in which he
deactivates data in order to impersonate
him the first member of the crew to
realize something is wrong is Wesley
Crusher who notices that lure while
disguised as data speaks using
contractions like can't instead of
cannot or I'm instead of I am this is
strange to Wesley because data never
uses contractions yes I do use language
more formally than lore the only problem
is that data totally uses contractions
clearly the no contraction rule isn't
established before datalore in the
season premiere data jokes about Q
saying at least we're acquainted with
the judge Captain later in the same
episode questioned by the elderly McCoy
about his strange demeanor data says I'm
an Android in fact the rule doesn't seem
to be set in stone even after the
contraction rule is established in
datalore he tells Picard quote I'm fine
at the end of the episode and continues
to occasionally use contractions in
subsequent episodes in the end it all
works out and lore schemes are foiled
the real lesson here is that you
shouldn't try to take your brother's
place or Wesley Crusher will make up
lies about you shut up Wesley
are you a Trekkie who wants to see if
our picks line up with yours or do you
just want some shows that can help you
squeeze out a few tears either way here
are our nominations for the saddest
episodes of Star Trek ever
after a long and stressful Mission the
crew of the defiant receives a distress
call from a Starfleet captain
Shipwrecked on an inhospitable planet
at first the crew can only hear the
transmission from Captain Lisa Cusack
but can't respond soon Chief O'Brien's
tinkering establishes two-way
communication with the Defiance still
days away and Cusack having nothing to
do but slowly suffocate Cisco
establishes shifts for his officers
including himself to sit by the
communicator and keep their stranded
colleague company but some part of me is
always saying
[Music]
they may not be here tomorrow Captain
Cusack proves to be a gift to her
would-be Rescuers with the crew
struggling under the weight of the
Dominion War Cusack happily gives a
sympathetic ear to their problems she
helps O'Brien see he's keeping his
friends at arm's length because he's
afraid of growing too close to people
the war may take away from him and let
Cisco see why having his girlfriend
Cassidy Yates aboard the defiant bothers
him so much when the defiant finally
reaches its destination the crew is
shocked to discover Captain Cusack has
been dead for three years an energy
barrier surrounding the planet somehow
allowed for the Defiance Transmissions
to reach her in the past and hers to
connect with them in the future they
bring Cusack back to DS9 for an Irish
wake where the crew gathers to honor her
and to share the lessons their friend
taught them
at first Star Trek the next Generations
The Offspring seems like it might become
another exploration of the rights of
synthetic life after data surprises his
friends with the reveal that he's
created a new Android named LOL Captain
Picard is extremely concerned about the
ramifications
his fears are realized when a Starfleet
Admiral demands Lyle be taken off the
Enterprise to be placed under the
supervision of Starfleet scientists
Hallie Todd's portrayal as data's
Android daughter Lal is sweet funny and
ultimately heartbreaking like her father
Lawless confused by human behavior but
does her best to learn doing things like
grabbing Will Riker without warning for
a kiss or telling data that she believes
she has mastered the art of humor
because so many children laugh at her
Lala unexpectedly grows beyond data's
programming and develops the ability to
feel emotions unfortunately she can't
survive them after being overcome with
fear at the prospect of separation from
data her systems experience a critical
failure in her final moments she thanks
data for her life and tells him she
loves him when he tells her he wishes he
could feel the same for her she says she
will love enough for them both
Star Trek has a lot of ways of forcing
illusions on its characters when it
comes to these Illusions perhaps no
other Trek story proves as harmful to
one of its Heroes as ds9's hard time
while visiting the agrathe Homeworld
Chief Miles O'Brien is wrongly convicted
of Espionage rather than maintaining
physical prisons the agrathi punished
criminals by implanting memories of
incarceration including hunger isolation
and torture when Kira arrives to pick up
miles he's only been in their custody
for a few hours but he has memories of
20 years worth of prison
the Miles O'Brien who returns to DS9 is
a changed man he prefers to be alone
he's angry he refuses to see his
therapist and he threatens his best
friend Dr Bashir
he eventually gets violent assaulting
Quark for taking too long to serve him a
drink and even coming close to hitting
his daughter it's revealed that during
most of his time in the virtual prison
miles has a kind patient cell mate named
ichar after 20 years in the cell with
him wrongly believing his friend is
hiding food from him miles murders HR
hallucinations of eachar appear to
O'Brien on DS9 only disappearing when on
the brink of ending his own life O'Brien
finally accepts help from Bashir and it
turns out that even in the future
there's no easy cure for PTSD
written by late author Harlan Ellison
Star Trek the Original Series the city
on the edge of forever is a time travel
episode that forces Captain Kirk into an
impossible decision the trouble begins
when a temporarily insane bones flees
into a sentient time portal calling
itself the guardian of forever shortly
after he enters the timeline is altered
so that Starfleet basically ceases to
exist
kirkenspock follow through the portal
ending up in New York City during the
Great Depression believing they're
homeless the kind and forward-thinking
Edith Keeler helps the pair and she and
Kirk fall in love
unfortunately Spock discovers that
Keeler is the subject of the timeline
shift Keeler is supposed to be killed in
a car accident if she survives she'll
help spread a message of pacifism that
keeps America out of World War II which
in turn leads to Germany's Victory but
she was right peace was the way she was
right but at the wrong time when the
moment comes for Kirk to decide it's
fast and brutal Kirk and Spock fine
bones and Edith crosses the street to
join them without paying attention to
traffic when the car destined to kill
Edith approaches Kirk not only stops
himself from helping but holds on to
bones and stops him from interfering as
well when the trio returns to their crew
Kirk has no comforting words for his
friends and ignores the guardian of
forever's invitations for other Journeys
Through Time
one of Star Trek's first attempts to
explore the plight of lgbtq plus people
was in tng's 1992 episode the outcast we
use a pronoun that is neutral
I do not think there is really a
translation
the Enterprise encounters the
androgynous race the Janai who needs
help finding a lost shuttle in its crew
the Enterprise crew determines the
shuttle is in a pocket of what they call
null space
Reichert partners with the Janai named
Soren to find a way to get into null
space to rescue the missing crew the
attraction between Riker and Soren is
noticed by Riker's friends and the other
Janai soaring confides in Riker not only
that she's attracted to him but that she
identifies as a female for a Chennai to
identify as either male or female is
forbidden and others like Soren are
treated as outcasts
if they're discovered they will undergo
a kind of conversion therapy called
psychotactic treatment Riker and Soren's
relationship is discovered before it
gets very far Soren makes a passionate
speech in front of the other Janai and
Riker tries to intervene he takes
responsibility for everything and offers
to take Soren with him the Janai refuse
ignoring Picard's warnings Riker and
Wharf attempt to break Soarin free
they easily overpower the Chennai guards
but once Riker is alone with Soren she's
a different person
the psychotectic treatments are complete
and Soren believed she had been ill and
is now well Riker desperately professes
his love for her but Soren simply
answers I'm sorry and walks away
in this Bittersweet DS9 episode Ben
Cisco is believed killed when struck by
a bolt of energy during an accident on
the defiant for years after the accident
Ben continues to briefly appear before
his son Jake only to eventually fade
away like a ghost into Subspace
after returning to Earth Jake marries
and finally publishes his novel anslem
to wide acclaim but after he becomes
obsessed with saving his father Jake
abandons writing to pursue scientific
study and his marriage falls apart
Jake determines his father keeps
appearing when and where he does because
the accident connected him to Jake and
that the only way to save him is for
Jake to die during his father's next
appearance
as an elderly man Jake awakens to his
father smiling at him and Jake Reveals
His plan
Ben is crushed but it's too late Jake
has already taken the drugs that will
kill him as he dies Jake tells his
father he's doing it not just for Ben
but for the boy that I was
he needs you
more than you know
as the elderly Jake dies Ben appears
years earlier during the accident on the
defiant and Ducks the bolt of energy
just in time
if you aren't already tearing up then
embracing his young son while crying
grateful tears should push you over the
edge
This truly Bleak episode opens with the
marriage of Tom Paris and bolana Torres
but they don't get to enjoy their
honeymoon the molecular cohesion of
Voyager is deteriorating affecting both
the ship itself and the crew inside
balana is the first to die
the crew discovers something shocking
in the previous season episode demon
Voyager had landed on a planet that
created a complete duplicate of the ship
and all her crew out of biomimetic fluid
tuvak and chicote determined their ship
as the duplicate and they're now all
dying because of exposure to radiation
from their enhanced warp core
everything the duplicate crew tries ends
in Failure when they try to find Solace
on a planet they're chased off by aliens
the ship and crew deteriorate too fast
for them to make it back to their
Homeworld and even an attempt to launch
a capsule with all of their logs fails
few of their crew are left by the time
they detect the original Voyager on
their sensors
they try hailing the ship and the
original Voyager responds but by the
time they get there all that's left of
the duplicate ship and crew is formless
fluid floating in space
sadly the episode in which we learned
the most about the mysterious Star Trek
Discovery character Arium is Project
Daedalus and also the same episode in
which she dies
it had been clear for a number of
episodes that something was taking over
Arium and forcing her to act against her
will and project Daedalus opens with
Arium reviewing her memories and
deleting many of them including the
tragic loss of her husband just after
they had eloped the discovery crew
finally figures out Arium is being
manipulated by control section 31's
threat assessment AI but only after
Arium is alone with Michael and neon on
the ransacked section 31 HQ Arium nearly
kills her colleagues but regains enough
control to insist Michael kill her by
opening an airlock while she's in it
Michael refuses insisting Arium can
fight control but neon takes the choice
out of Michael's hands and opens the
airlock
barium is shot into space and dies but
before she succumbs Tilly uploads the
memory of her on the beach with her
fiance so she can see it one more time
the Star Trek Enterprise episode Terra
Prime mainly deals with the Enterprise's
conflict with the group of the same name
led by John Frederick Paxton Tara Prime
is a xenophobic extremist group
dedicated to removing all aliens and
alien influence from Earth among his
crueler tactics Paxton takes DNA from to
Paul and trip and uses it to create a
half-human half Vulcan clone infant he
displays it as a propaganda tool calling
it an Abomination and uses it as
leverage after he takes to Paul and trip
hostage
Terra Prime is defeated but the baby
doesn't survive the episode flocks
initially believes the baby's illness
and resulting death is due to the
inherent incompatibility of human and
Vulcan DNA but in the final scene a
devastated trip tells to Paul that the
doctor discovered there was a flaw in
the technique used to create the child
and that a human Vulcan child might
survive to Paul reaches out and grabs
Tripp's hand in support a powerful
gesture considering her species and its
philosophies towards emotion
shortly after the Enterprise encounters
a probe Captain Sean Luke Picard
collapses on the bridge and wakes up to
a woman named delene who claims she's
his wife and tells him that his name is
Cayman
understandably picardis convinced
something deceptive is going on
initially believing he's on a Holodeck
after five years of no rescue from or
contact with the Enterprise Picard
accepts his new life on the planet Katan
including falling in love with a lean
and regularly trying and failing to
master the katanian flute the scenes
occasionally cut back to the Enterprise
where only minutes have passed but on
Katan years have gone by for Picard and
his new family
finally an elderly Picard attends a
celebration with his children and
grandchildren which turns out to be the
launching of the same probe that the
Enterprise encounters the truth is
finally revealed that the probe is given
Picard the vision of a lifetime so
someone will remember Katan and its
people
after the probe deactivates and Picard
wakes up about 25 minutes after it
begins transmitting the crew retrieves
it and Riker brings the package it
contains to his captain
inside the box is cayman's flute which
Picard remembers how to play thanks to
Decades of a completely separate life
he's lived and instantly lost
after returning from a mission where he
went over security procedures for
upcoming peace talks on DS9 O'Brien
notices everyone is acting strange Keiko
is doing everything she can to keep
their daughter away from him Cisco is
giving his Engineers orders without
talking to him first but Shear is
hounding him about getting a physical
and all it takes is a 30-second
conversation with Jake Cisco for Kira to
jump in and tell Jake to go see his
father
it gets to the point where O'Brien
worries keiko's trying to poison him
O'Brien uses his engineering know-how to
escape DS9 in a Runabout and rush to the
parata system to warn them and see if he
can get to the bottom of things he
reaches The Hideout of the paraden
rebels and the truth is revealed the
real O'Brien was imprisoned and a
replicant copy was made of him and sent
back to DS9 in his stead to disrupt the
peace talks
the parade and Rebels discovered the
plan rescued the real O'Brien and
informed DS9 of the plot which explains
why everyone was acting strange around
him the replicant O'Brien having just
arrived on Parada knows none of this
critically injured by one of the Rebels
the replicant dies calling out keiko's
name and begging the real O'Brien to
tell Keiko he loves her
asborg really Beyond saving when can you
trust an omnipotent trickster Captain
John Luke Picard had some pretty heavy
decisions to make aboard the USS
Enterprise keep watching to see the
absolute best
in the series premiere of Star Trek the
Next Generation Riker first meets his
new captain in a ready room and is given
his first order right away it's an order
given sternly and sets the tone for
Picard as a cold by the book commanding
officer but over the course of the
series the two would form one of just a
few genuine friendships for Captain
Picard and his choice to appoint him
first officer would alter the trajectory
of his life in that same first episode
one of Picard's next acts as Captain was
to instruct his new number one to
prevent him from making an ass of
himself with the children on the ship
I'm not a family man Riker yeah
Starfleet has given me a ship with
children aboard over the course of the
series Riker would help Picard go from a
stoic stick in the mud who preferred to
stay in arm's length from his crew to a
man with friendly relationships with
those under his commit one could argue
that the mere Act of recruiting data
could be one of the boldest decisions
Picard ever made despite the Android
having a long and distinguished service
record that would warrant just about any
Starship Captain bringing him aboard but
while other officers may have seen data
as a mere machine Captain Picard and
bills on the Enterprise learned to see
him as so much more even though visitors
were routinely surprised I must admit
Commander
I didn't think you'd be so
personable aboard the Enterprise Picard
and his crew saw data as a person and
when his rights as an individual came
under attack they leapt to his defense
and when data was ordered to be turned
over to Starfleet as property in the
measure of a man it was Picard who was
at the Forefront of the fight demanding
they could judge and decide his status
it was Picard who acted as his defense
counsel in one of the most important
acts he'd perform as Captain and act
with consequences that continue to
reverberate through the Star Trek
universe even today in the first season
of The Next Generation there didn't seem
to be any set chief engineer on the
Enterprise but in the second season
premiere Picard would promote Helmsman
Jordi laforge to the permanent spot at
the head of the ship's engine room to
audiences it may have seemed like an odd
jump for the young officer but it proved
to be one of the key changes on the ship
after its first Rocky year the forge
went on to become one of the standouts
on the series and was even ranked by
screenwranch as the franchise's best
engineering Chiefs he'd solve crisis
after after crisis including several
Galactic threats and it never would have
been possible if he stayed a mere pilot
or been moved to a different post
one of the most unexpected turns of
events in the entire run of Star Trek
the Next Generation occurred in the
third season episode sins of the father
essentially a Sci-Fi political drama the
episode brought the action to the
Klingon Homeworld with the sudden
accusation of treason made against
wharf's dead father turning up on the
Enterprise is wharf's long-lost brother
Kern who wants wharfed to travel home to
defend their family's honor but when
Kern is the victim of an assassination
attempt Wharf finds himself alone and
Captain Picard steps in to help not as
captain of the Enterprise but is a
trusted friend with Picard's assistance
new evidence is discovered along with a
direct eyewitness that clears warf's
father of the crime to prevent a civil
war however Warf takes the fall but
averts a death sentence thanks to the
evidence Picard revealed leaving Justice
for another day in season 3's Hollow
Pursuits we met a very unusual Starfleet
officer Lieutenant Reginald Barclay
Barclay was far from this steady skilled
and capable men and women of Starfleet
Barclay was awkward clumsy and lacking
in confident it's he was a social
outcast who struggled to fit in among
the more gregarious and bold crew of the
Enterprise I've examined Barclay's
psychological profile he has a history
of seclusive Tendencies when it became
known that he wasn't Measuring Up
Commander Riker wanted him off the ship
insisting he had no place on the
Enterprise and suspecting that Barclay's
previous commanders might have given him
recommendations just to get rid of him
but just when it seemed like Picard
might follow Barclay's previous captains
and send him packing he decided to do
something nobody had done before reach
out to Barclay with a caring
compassionate helping hand instead of
transferring the so-called problem
officer Picard instructed Jordy to
become his best friend
with all due respect for my best friend
I can barely tolerate being in the same
room with a man eventually the crew came
to appreciate Barclay for all his unique
talents and skills and together helped
him come out of his shell eventually
he'd helped bring the stranded crew of
Voyager home safely saving hundreds of
lives the mischievous cue was initially
presented as a malevolent Godlike entity
with Sinister but mysterious motives he
tormented the crew in the premiere
episode and popped up again throughout
the series to cause mischief and Mayhem
aboard the USS Enterprise
I am on capita
he's back but it's in the third season
episode Deja q that Picard makes his
most important decision regarding the
all-powerful cue exiled from his own
people Q was turned into a mere mortal
and sought refuge on the Enterprise when
he became the target of a vengeful alien
race Picard chose to help him and
provide a cue with a safe haven mostly
[Music]
it seems human enough to me it wasn't an
easy call and few would have blamed him
if he hadn't agreed to come to his Aid
particularly as Q's presence proved to
be a danger to the ship but helping Q
show the trickster how special humans
and Picard really were Q later felt he
owed Jean-Luc a debt of gratitude he'd
repay in Cupid tapestry and in the
series finale all good things helping
him learn life lessons and save mankind
too had Picard not intervened we also
may have never witnessed the Q Civil War
on boy Voyager nor his return in season
2 of Star Trek Picard
who watches the Watchers may be one of
the most quintessential episodes of Star
Trek the Next Generation it all starts
when a secret Starfleet research team is
discovered by a pre-industrial society
called the mintokits and in the ensuing
confusion where the Enterprise comes to
assist begin to believe that Picard is
an all-powerful God the prime directive
demands they not interfere but the
damage is done and while the Starfleet
expert advises they hand down a set of
religious tenants to mitigate the damage
Picard outright refuses instead the
captain speaks directly to the Primitive
people and plainly explains the
situation in the end the mintokans begin
to understand the truth of what happened
and agree to go their separate ways but
not before gifting Picard with a
hand-woven tapestry to remember their
time together one of the major guest
stars to appear on Star Trek the Next
Generation who originated in the
original series was Mr Spock's father
sir the Elder Vulcan Ambassador had
appeared in the original series and in
three of the five future films before he
showed up on the Next Generation in the
season 3 of episode Sarah coming aboard
the ship to conduct final negotiations
with a mysterious alien race it soon
discovered that the Aging Vulcan is
Afflicted with a rare disease that is
sapping him of his mental abilities and
his logic in the climax of the episode
Picard selflessly agrees to a dangerous
mind melt with sarik in order to help
him stabilize his condition so he can
follow through with his final mission
the meld is a success but not without
consequences and Picard undergoes some
serious trauma as a result
Picard's joining with sarek's mind gives
him a more centered and measured sense
of control it also gave him a profound
connection to Ambassador Spock who he'd
meet and melt with in the episode
unification which in turn may even have
helped fuel his desire to help the
romulans in the follow-up Star Trek
Picard when the Enterprise first made
contact with the Borg they were shown to
be little more than a robotic hive mind
intent on absorbing life into their
Collective but in the episode iborg Dr
Crusher convinces Picard to bring aboard
an injured and dying Borg they find at
the site of a crashed morgue ship
initially Picard wants to use the Drone
as a weapon against the collective using
a computer virus sabotage their entire
network
terminal one but as the board recovers
it begins to show signs of individuality
eventually taking the name Hugh and
showing an unusually strong moral
compass ultimately Picard chooses to
respect Hughes right to autonomy and
lets Hugh make his own choice about his
future Hugh decides to return to the
collective and Picard's greatest hope is
realized that Hugh's sense of self and
morality could be just as contagious to
the Borg as any virus
throughout the fourth season trouble was
brewing in the Klingon Empire beginning
with the death of the former Chancellor
Kim Peck it's determined that duras the
same man who'd frame dwarf's father is
guilty of the assassination as well as
the murder of warf's ex-girlfriend
that's enough reason for Worf to kill
duros in ritual combat the mysterious
gauron is named the new Chancellor but
duras's powerful family haunts the
Empire and it all comes to a head in the
two-part season Ender Redemption with
gauron about to take his place as leader
of his people the house of duros with
the outside help of the romulans attempt
to take control themselves torn between
his people and his duty Wharf sides with
gauron and asks that Picard and
Starfleet join him unable to get
directly involved in what is deemed in
internal Klingon Affair Picard instead
hatches a plan to expose the Romulan
alliance with the house of duros the
plan works gauron is installed as
Chancellor thanks to Picard's help and
war finally regains the honor he had
lost in sins of the father it's a bold
and risky move for Picard but it sets
off a chain of events that would have
after effects for years spilling over
into Deep Space Nine years later as
gauron owes much of his legacy to
Starfleet and Picard's assistance
recruited by a corrupt Admiral to help
locate a supposed bajoran terrorist
ensignolarin was brought to the
Enterprise against Picard's explicit
objections but when Ensign Roe uncovered
a plot to supply cardassian militants
with illegal weapons she didn't know who
to trust with the help from gainan
Ensign Rowe placed her faith in Captain
Picard to help her out of the situation
the island is very selective about whom
she calls a friend rather than toss her
into the brig for taking part in a
corruption Scandal Picard impressed by
her Integrity asks her to remain on the
Enterprise it may have seemed like an
obvious choice for viewers in the moment
who signs and row distinguished herself
in the episode but she was coming from a
federation penal colony and her
reputation was less than stuller giving
her a position on the bridge of the
flagship of the Federation was a risky
call and it paid off in Spades as Rogue
became a standout officer and a fan
favorite character when Star Trek the
Next Generation first debuted in 1987 it
was living in the shadow of the original
Star Trek series and Picard himself was
being measured harshly against his
counterpart James T Kirk as played by
franchise Legend William Shatner
thankfully Patrick Stewart played the
role masterfully and Picard eventually
became equally as beloved in his own way
in the first Next Generation film in
1994 Star Trek generations the two
captains of the enter prize would come
face to face thanks to a fateful
decision by Captain Picard both captains
became trapped in a mysterious
time-bending anomaly called the Nexus
when Picard attempts to escape and stop
the villainous Soren he discovers Kirk
inside the Nexus and recruits him for
the task together they stop Soren and in
the melee Kirk dies at Soren's hands but
saves millions of lives in the process
the decision to bring Kirk back for one
more mission may be the most important
choice he ever made not just to save
lives but to give trekkies the moment
they'd been waiting for the meeting of
the two best Enterprise captains
Star Trek creators have proven they know
how to turn on the funny since the
beginning whether it's entire episodes
hilarious scenes or little more than a
couple of lines of dialogue here's what
we count as the funniest moments in the
history of Star Trek one of the most fun
conflicts to witness on Star Trek Deep
Space Nine is the back and forth between
Constable Odo and the scheming Ferengi
Quark perhaps their funniest exchange
happens in season 4's the way of the
warrior just before the epic battle
between the eponymous station and a
fleet of Klingon ships finding Quark
outside his bar Odo tells him it's time
to head to the emergency shelter but
Quark assures Odo he intends to defend
his property Quark isn't known for being
able to defend himself against so much
as a Tribble much less battle-hardened
Klingon Warriors so Odo is
understandably skeptical the bartender
produces a box that he thinks holds a
disrupter pistol when he opens the Box
boldly claiming he'll be ready for the
Klingons rather than a weapon there's a
note inside without skipping a beat or
asking permission Odo grabs the note and
reads it it's from quark's Brother rum
informing him he gutted his disrupter to
fix their replicator it's here that Odo
hits Quark with a real Zinger
with what
Deanna Troy's intrusive and flirtatious
mother luwaksana played by the late
magell Barrett provides a tremendous
amount of comic relief whenever she
shows up in her third appearance on Star
Trek the Next Generation her predicament
forces Captain Picard to deliver a
speech so ridiculously over the top that
even if you've never watched TNG you've
likely seen the memes inspired by it
after Will Riker Deanna and luaxana are
kidnapped by the Ferengi day Montag
luwaksana succeeds in getting Riker and
her daughter sent back to the Enterprise
by promising to be tug's lover when the
Enterprise contacts talk waxanna
pretends she doesn't want to be rescued
telling Picard that it's over between
them Deanna figures out what her mother
is doing and tells Picard he will have
to fight for her in a display so
melodramatic it would even make William
Shatner groan Picard professes his love
for luaxana threatens tug with
Annihilation and recites famous lines
from Shakespearean sonnets with as much
grandiose Flair as he can muster
my love
is a fever
longing still for that which longer
nurses the disease
dwarf what is in disgust looking like
he's about to rage puke it's Picard like
you've never seen him and probably
wouldn't want to see him again
in Star Trek the Original Series the
season 2 episode The Trouble with
Tribble starts off on a serious note the
Enterprise is already on its way to deep
space station k-7 but they put the pedal
to the metal when they receive an alert
that their destination is under attack
this alert proves to be a false alarm
though dangers do await at k-7 a
domineering Federation bureaucrat a
Klingon spy and a space Trader named
Cyrano Jones who sells members of the
Enterprise crew some of the most
Troublesome pets in the Galaxy Tribbles
The Trouble with Tribbles is a classic
and one of the first examples of a
whimsically goofy original series
episode that makes a point of not taking
itself too seriously from the countless
puffballs that multiply faster than a
gremlin in a tropical storm to the
ridiculous bar room brawl between the
Klingons and Enterprise crew to The
Peddler Cyrano Jones willing to risk
life and limb in order to score a free
drink the trouble with triples is a
great time to celebrate his upcoming
marriage to Jadzia in the DS9 episode
titled you are cordially invited Wharf
invites Chief O'Brien and Dr Bashir
among others to the ritual of kalhaya
thinking they can expect the Klingon
version of a bachelor party they happily
accept but rather than drinking or
exotic dancers the path to calhaya
involves fasting for four days and
nights being drained of blood hanging
from a pole over intense heat and other
creative forms of torture one Wharf
abruptly cancels the wedding Bashir and
O'Brien are thrilled to cut their
torment short they head straight to
quarks for a feast but before they can
sink their teeth in Cisco and martak
arrive to let them know the weddings
back on when Quark takes their untouched
food away you can practically hear them
whining like disappointed puppies
after several vows from both friends
that they're going to kill Worf the
wedding finally arrives part of the
friend's Duty as per Klingon tradition
is to attack warfinjatzia with blunted
weapons called mastakas while everyone
else applauds the newlyweds kiss Bashir
looks like Obi-Wan Kenobi waiting for a
force field to come down
our talk final
word Bashir and O'Brien Rush Wharf and
Chad Zia with cries of rage and the
credits rolled to sounds of the mock
battle one of the best Star Trek films
featuring the original cast is 1986's
Star Trek 4 the Voyage Home in order to
answer an alien probe's call which is
blindly triggering power losses and
apocalyptic storms on Earth Kirk and his
crew must go back in time to recover a
humpback whale a species extinct by the
23rd Century while original series Sent
the heroes back in time on multiple
occasions none of those stories feel as
natural or believable as in Star Trek IV
rather than experiencing any particular
physical threat the biggest challenge
they face is culture shock they don't
have money when they try to use a bus
they're foiled by the need for exact
change and in particular they're
confused by what Spock calls quote
colorful metaphors I.E all the swearing
the best scene involves kirkensbach
trying to earn the trust of the marine
biologist Dr Jillian Taylor Kirk is
attempting and failing to seem like the
normal one compared to Spock when Kirk
suggests the three of them get dinner
one of the most natural adorably funny
moments in the franchise unfolds you
guys like Italian
no no no yes no yes
I love Italian
due to the meddling of the mischievous
entity Q one of Star Trek's greatest
villains Captain Picard his senior staff
and Picard's Old Flame vosh find
themselves transported to Sherwood
Forest in season 4's Cupid there's
little about Cupid that won't make you
laugh Picard and his senior officers are
made up as Robin Hood's merry men
including data who Bears the famous bald
Dome of Friar Tuck Wharf is predictably
the most incensed by the situation
famously complaining to Picard sir I
protest I am not a merry man the most
laugh out loud moment comes as Jordi
rests and plucks at his mandolin without
comment or permission Wharf calmly walks
over grabs the instrument and smashes it
against a nearby tree
the prime directive prohibits members of
Starfleet from interfering with the
natural progression of any society
outside the United Federation of planets
serving as a comically dangerous example
of why this code exists is the original
series season 2 episode a piece of the
action 100 years before the events of
the episode Sigma eosha 2 is visited by
the Earthship Horizon to help teach the
planet's natives The Horizon crew leaves
behind a number of books including a
non-fiction book titled Chicago mobs of
the 20s after the Horizon leaves the E
oceans come to see this book as a holy
text and base their entire culture on it
when Kirk Spock and McCoy beam down to
the planet they find a world where just
about every grown male dresses and
speaks like tough guys in mobster movies
people openly carry tommy guns up and
down the street as if there's nothing
strange about it a piece of the action
gets even funnier once Kirk and Spock
are outfitted in their own mobster
get-ups and Kirk attempts a Chicago
gangster impersonation Shatner wouldn't
fool anyone on Earth and it's tough to
tell whether that's intentional which
just makes the whole thing even funnier
early in season 5 of DS9 the series made
television history with trials and
tribulations where the cast of the show
is sent back in time to the 1967
original series episode The Trouble with
Tribbles this episode uses every
opportunity to poke fun at the franchise
O'Brien the tireless engineer is so lost
on the Enterprise that when he tries to
perform routine maintenance he takes out
all the nearby lights Bashir gets hit on
by a woman he's convinced is his
great-grandmother and afterward he
considers the possibility that if he
doesn't get involved with her he might
never be born hands down the best moment
comes when a waitress points out a table
full of Klingons everyone but Wharf is
confused because of course Klingons look
a lot different in the original series
it's the first time in the franchise
anyone acknowledges what appears to be a
glaring inconsistency and it comes off
perfectly
they are Klingons
and it is a long story
imagine you're suddenly transported to
the 23rd century and you need to use a
computer more advanced than anything
you'd ever seen now consider the
opposite scenario and that's what
happens in Star Trek 4. on their quest
to bring 20th century humpback whales
back to the 23rd Century Scotty McCoy
and Sulu are tasked with figuring out a
way to construct a makeshift aquarium
aboard the Bounty while Sulu secures an
aircraft Scotty and McCoy find a
Plexiglas manufacturer and pretend to be
famous scientists with an appointment to
tour the factory at the end of the tour
Scotty plans to offer the head of the
plant Dr Nichols the futuristic formula
for transparent aluminum but he needs to
use Nichol's computer to prove it can
work unfortunately Scotty has a little
trouble computer
computer
thinking he's figured it out McCoy hands
Scotty the mouse smiling widely Scotty
holds the mouse to his face like a
walkie-talkie and says Hello computer
just use the keyboard
1989's Star Trek 5 the final frontier is
considered one of the worst films in the
series though it is not without its
merits while it's one of the funnier
entries in the franchise some of its
detractors would argue that the movie's
over-reliance on humor weighs it down
but one easy uncharacteristically
slapstick moment in Star Trek 5 remains
as an incredibly uproarious gag after
the forces loyal to Spock's fanatical
Brothers cybox sees control of the
Enterprise Kirk Spock and McCoy are
imprisoned in the brig Scotty soon frees
them with explosives and the liberated
Trio makes a plan to sneak their way to
the emergency transmitter when the
subject of search parties comes up
Scotty gives them directions he's
confident will steer them clear of
cybach's people before they rush off
Kirk emphatically thanks Scotty and
calls him amazing turning and walking in
the other direction Scotty mutters
nothing amazing about it I know this
like the back of my ass
if that were true though he should have
easily been able to avoid that bulkhead
it's perfectly timed and classic
if you understand the context the single
word response Wharf delivers to Quark in
the season 4 DS9 episode of session
should make you laugh hard enough to
knock you out of any recliner couch or
captain's chair Dr Bashir and O'Brien
are sharing a drink in quarks bar
discussing the news that O'Brien's wife
Keiko is pregnant with another baby it's
just then that behind Bashir and O'Brien
Quark runs into Wharf and says did you
hear keiko's gonna have another baby to
understand what happens next you need to
know that five years earlier in the
season five TNG episode disaster much of
the Enterprise is rendered inoperable
and most of the crew is stranded in
different parts of the ship this of
course is when Keiko O'Brien pregnant
with her first baby goes into labor
while stuck in 10 forward as the most
qualified crew member but still with
precious little medical knowledge Wharf
is the one who's forced to assist with
keiko's pregnancy so this is why five
years later in a session when Quark
delivers the news wharf's immediate
reaction is to respond with a panicked
now
can you survive being torn apart Adam by
Adam how fast do you have to go before
you turn into a lizard and what's the
real deal with time travel anyway keep
watching to find out
the 1966 pilot episode of Star Trek
titled where no man has gone before
wasn't actually the first episode filmed
for the series two years before another
pilot called the cage was filmed
sporting a number of differences
including an entirely different Captain
instead of James T Kirk it was
Christopher Pike Manning the captain's
chair the same Pike who would later lead
Star Trek strange new Worlds the studio
didn't like the first pilot and
commissioned a second with a number of
changes including a new captain and
first officer after the second pilot
debuted the studio didn't want to waste
the footage from the cage so it was cut
up and used as flashbacks in the
two-part episode The Menagerie in the
Years prior to Home Video this led many
to believe they had actually watched the
cage on television in the 1960s decades
later in celebration of the franchise's
20th anniversary in 1986 the cage was
released on VHS and LaserDisc
reassembled using a mix of scenes from
The Menagerie and a black and white
print owned by Gene Roddenberry just a
year later a film archivist found the
original 30 35 millimeter color
negatives and in 1988 as a part of a
prime time special the cage finally
aired on TV
our seemingly emotionless beings Guided
by a strict sense of logic but that's
not quite true they have all the same
emotions as any human they've just
chosen to suppress them we've seen
emotional Vulcans a number of times in
Star Trek usually when their logic fails
them due to an outside influence illness
when they reject traditional Vulcan
teachings or during the debilitating
seven-year mating cycle known as ponfar
that's why most of us overlooked the
fact that even Vulcans aren't
indestructible
in the original Star Trek episode this
side of paradise Spock inhales the
spores of an alien flower and is
overcome with strong feelings of love in
the Next Generation episode saric the
Vulcan illness called Bandai Syndrome
causes a breakdown of cerex emotional
control in the Voyager episode Blood
Fever the Vulcan and sin voric becomes
rageful during his ponfar when unable to
take a Vulcan mate Star Trek Enterprise
meanwhile suggested that living among
humans can cause a Vulcan to be more
emotional because humans are a reminder
of the way Vulcans used to be listen to
me you're making a mistake when your
logic doesn't work you raise your voice
you've been on Earth too long
The Fifth Star Trek movie the final
frontier focused on Spock's half-brother
cybach and his rejection of Vulcan
tradition
before the time of the Vulcan Messiah
Surak founder of Vulcan logic Vulcans
were a warlike people fueled by emotions
but thanks to the teachings of Surak
Vulcans are now trained to repress
feelings through strict mental
discipline and sometimes undergo a
ritual called the culinar which purges
the last remnants of emotions
that said there are plenty of examples
of Vulcans who rebel against their
culture's tradition
airing for two seasons Star Trek the
Animated Series continued The Adventures
of the Starship Enterprise after the
original Show's cancellation with nearly
the entire cast of the original series
reprising their roles thanks to
animation the stories were able to
Envision truly wild aliens environments
and situations some of which were pretty
weird including an episode with a
gigantic 20-foot tall clone of Spock and
a race of beings who could separate
their head and legs the show was largely
seen today as a curious Oddity and given
its sometimes off-the-wall stories it's
not usually clear if it's meant to be
considered canonical the answer is a
little complicated most of Star Trek
never directly acknowledged anything
that happened in the series but there
are lots of small details that first
appeared in the animated series that
have shown up in live action track
Spock's home city of shikar is first
mentioned in the animated series and
referenced in Deep Space Nine and even
visited in Enterprise the animated
cat-like kazinti race is mentioned in
Picard and to the Klingon ship the
clothos gets a mention in Deep Space
Nine as well these are just a few of the
small Easter eggs scattered throughout
Trek Cannon so is it part of the main
Trek storyline was there ever a
two-story tall Spock clone running
around
the short answer is probably while many
of the details mentioned in the Animated
Series don't line up with timelines
later established in Trek proper modern
writers have used the cartoon as a
source of inspiration and cherry-picked
key elements for more canonical stories
Star Trek fans who only started watching
with the arrival of the movies might be
surprised to learn that the Klingons in
the original series were just human
looking beings with goatees and gold
tunics but when the franchise
transitioned to the big screen the
klingon's got a major facelift with a
big screen budget producers wanted a
more alien looking race and so the
Klingons suddenly had big forehead
ridges sharp teeth and a new unusual
language this is how the Klingons would
mostly remain later Star Trek the Next
Generation established them as an
honor-bound and ritualistically war-like
people who glorified combat as a
cultural tradition but their visual
changes weren't yet explained in fact
when three Klingons from the original
show appeared on Deep Space Nine they
sported ridged foreheads reinforcing the
notion that Klingons had simply always
looked this way but that would start to
change in the DS9 episode trials and
tribulations when it was acknowledged
for the first time what happened some
kind of genetic engineering a viral
mutation
we do not discuss it with Outsiders
episode of Enterprise several years
later explained the changes canonically
as the result of a genetic plague while
a clever idea and a solid story it
created the expectation among fans that
changes to designs should have an
in-story explanation causing serious
discussion when Star Trek Discovery once
again updated the look of the Klingons
the Vulcan salute scene in Star Trek has
become an indelible part of Pop Culture
but what does it really mean and where
did it come from
the first question is pretty simple as
the salute is a visual gesture
representing the off-spoken Vulcan
greeting with long and prosperous
generally Vulcans and Star Trek use the
salute as both a greeting and a goodbye
meaning it's essentially the science
fiction aloha we have actor Leonard
Nimoy to thank for its Origins having
come up with the salute for the episode
amok time when Spock returns to Vulcan
Nimoy told star trek.com the idea came
when I saw the way director Joe pevny
was staging the scene he had me approach
to Pal and I felt a greeting gesture was
called for so I suggested it to Joe who
accepted it immediately Nimoy has gone
on to explain that he was inspired by
Jewish religious leaders from his youth
who used the same gesture During certain
ritual prayers saying when I saw the
split fingered gesture of these men I
was entranced I learned to do it simply
because it seemed so magical
James T Kirk was the first captain of
the 1701 Enterprise right well no we
already learned that Captain Christopher
Pike was the original captain in the
cage but you'd be wrong again introduced
in Star Trek the Animated Series episode
the counter-clock incident Captain
Robert April is actually the first
person to helm the classic Enterprise
ncc-1701 as mentioned earlier the
Animated Series isn't 100 officially
Canon but this is one bit of background
information from that series that
writers of Discovery Drew from not only
did he get a name drop in the first
season as one of starfleet's most
decorated officers but Pike's own
service record on screen shows that he
took command of the Enterprise from its
previous Captain Robert April April
himself makes an appearance in strange
new worlds finally in his true canonical
form
how does time travel work in the Trek
universe the short answer is however the
writers want it to you'll probably never
find a consistent answer across
different episodes and movies two
episodes of the original series and the
film The Voyage Home had the Enterprise
use the slingshot maneuver to create a
Time Warp by manipulating the gravity of
a star while at least two episodes have
used the guardian of forever Ascension
portal to move back and forth through
time but the question remains how do the
rules of time travel work in Star Trek
in most episodes the franchise has used
Back to the Future rules where changing
history results in an altered present
this kind of time travel was most
notably used in city on the edge of
forever in which the time-stranded
members of the Enterprise couldn't
prevent the death of Edith Keeler
without destroying their own future
hundreds of years later the movie First
Contact and the Deep Space Nine episode
past tense also played by the same roles
some stories however have used causality
Loop rules where we discovered that the
travel back in time was part of History
all along and they just didn't know it
this is how the Next Generation
two-parter times Arrow worked with the
crew discovering data's head on Earth
buried for hundreds of years even before
they traveled back in time but more
recently a third time travel rule set
appeared in the 2009 Star Trek movie
from JJ Abrams in which the Romulan
neroes travel back in time resulted in
the creation of an entirely new
branching reality ultimately the writers
of Star Trek seem to use whatever rules
they want to serve the story in front of
them and space is weird so that's okay
the 1967 Star Trek episode The Squire of
gothos features an enigmatic villain
named trelane a powerful trickster who
kidnaps Kirk and Sulu off the bridge of
the Enterprise after their rescued
trelane appears on the bridge of the
ship without explanation and with no
discernible technology transports the
entire Bridge crew down to his Planet he
magically changes People's Clothing
plays childish games with the crew and
speaks to them in French
later they're put on trial where trelane
is the judge in full courtroom dress
eventually his games are put to an end
not by Kirk but by a pair of
non-corporeal beings who scold trelane
for misbehaving revealing him to be
little more than a child of his god-like
race if this sounds familiar it's
because this all bears a striking
resemblance to the character of Q who
tormented the Enterprise D in Next
Generation in a very similar way Hugh
also kidnaps crew members pops onto the
bridge of the Enterprise causes
impromptu costume changes and has more
than once dressed as a judge and put the
crew of the Enterprise on trial he's
also fond of speaking French
our Trek has dozens of all-powerful
beings so the question of whether
trelane is himself a q has been the
subject of debate according to actor
John Delancey who played Q the answer is
a clear and unequivocal yes according to
a 2010 interview with star trek.com and
even though it's non-canon the novel Q
squared by Peter David confirmed that
trelane was a renegade who hailed from
the race known as the Q Continuum though
nothing on screen is yet confirmed it
the Holodeck has provided Star Trek
opportunities to venture to new worlds
within the confines of the ship able to
recreate everything from a Romulan
landscape to a jazz club the room uses a
combination of hard light Holograms
force fields and replicator technology
which together can create the illusion
of an endless fully interactive 3D
environment and thanks to replicators a
person in the Holodeck can even leave
the confines of the room and take a
simulated object with them we've also
seen the capabilities of the Holodeck
expanded on a few occasions Voyager
kicks Holograms up a notch by inventing
holographic technology that allows their
doctor to roam the ship freely in a
later Voyager episode Dark Frontier the
crew tied two holodecks together
allowing one team to operate on a
recreation of Voyager while the other
simulates a mission on a board cube with
actions in one affecting the other
likewise in the killing game an alien
race called the herogen take over
Voyager and install Hollow emitters
throughout the ship turning the multiple
decks into one massive simulation of
1940s wartime France
the holodecks have been shown to be a
huge drain on the ship's power and are
usually the first things shut down in
emergencies they are also extremely
vulnerable to malfunctions with power
surges switching off safety protocols or
making exit impossible this has made the
holodecks the source of much drama since
the crew can get trapped in a dangerous
world within their own ship and
intelligent Holograms might just try to
take over the Enterprise once in a while
one of the most fundamental pieces of
Technology on Star Trek The Transporter
is also one of the most baffling since
it converts a person into energy and
then reforms them at another location
many have wondered if a transporter
actually kills you and creates a
duplicate of you on the other end it's
probably the best scientific and
philosophical question the series has
raised but it's rarely addressed on
screen
no reason you want my atom scattered all
over space boy
according to the science of the show The
Transporter works by scanning and
converting your physical matter into a
stream of all your subatomic particles
once a location is selected for
transport your matter stream is beamed
there and reassembled the same particles
that were you before are still you after
but the problems arise when it's not the
same particles such as when a duplicate
of Will Riker was created by a second
transporter beam in the episode's Second
Chances if the original matter that was
Riker rematerialized on the ship where
did the matter that made the second
Riker come from a lot can go wrong and
it often does
thank you
[Applause]
because the transporter doesn't have to
reconstitute you using the same atoms it
can replace them with new ones using the
blueprint the transporter created of
your energy pattern this is why some
believe a transporter is a kill and copy
machine we're left to take the word a
fictional Star Trek scientists the
transporter doesn't kill you it
transports the real you body soul and
all
introduced in the first episode of
Enterprise the character referred to by
fans as future guy was a projection that
spoke to people in the 22nd century from
a far-off future through his vague
silhouette he would speak to the
villainous sulaban to influence events
in his past for his own ends another
time traveler named Daniels traveled
back to recruit Archer to help stop him
and put an end to what he called the
temporal Cold War but who was this
future guy unfortunately the series
abandoned the plot thread before viewers
would get concrete answers speaking at a
convention in 2009 series producer
Brandon Braga and former showrunner
Manny Koto claimed that a proposed Fifth
Season would have revealed future guy as
a Romulan attempting to change history
but on Twitter in 2015 Braga stated that
the original plan was that the mystery
villain would have been revealed as
Captain Archer himself attempting to
manipulate his Destiny from the future
in the expanded universe of Star Trek
novels the shadowy Baddie was revealed
to be jamrin harnath a 28th Century time
agent who worked for an organization
called the the order of the Omega on
screen there's yet to be a definitive
answer
whether or not going faster than warp 10
is possible is a question that's plagued
track for decades because the series
seems to have Rewritten the rules of
warp travel more than once in the
original Trek series episode journey to
Babel it's said that speeds above warp
10 are unsafe while in the changeling
anything above warp 15 is called a
multi-warp meanwhile in an animated
series episode the Enterprise went as
fast as warp 36. by the time of the next
Generation it seems that the fastest
possible speed a Starship could achieve
was warp 9.9 according to the Star Trek
Voyager episode threshold anything warp
10 or Beyond was infinite velocity and
meant you would exist at every point in
the universe simultaneously
time and distance would have no meaning
but in achieving warp 10 Tom Paris and
Captain Janeway wound up evolving into
slug-like creatures so while it seems
that achieving such speeds are
technically possible they're not really
recommended still there are other ways
of traveling the stars that are faster
than warp 9.9
we've seen a slipstream drive in use on
Voyager and a protostar drive on Star
Trek Prodigy both moving ships beyond
the highest warp speeds and the sport
drive on Discovery Cuts speed out of the
equation entirely just putting you
wherever you need to be using the power
of space mushrooms
wait Quentin Tarantino almost made a
Star Trek movie and it was going to be
R-rated like Pulp Fiction in space yes
keep watching for the details about what
could have been
if Quentin Tarantino doesn't strike you
as the kind of director Paramount would
have had on its shortlist for Star Trek
you'd be right the humble beginnings of
Tarantino's never made sci-fi
Blockbuster came from Tarantino himself
not the studio Tarantino is an admitted
fan of the franchise who has cited the
original series the city on the edge of
forever and the Next Generation episode
yesterday's Enterprise as personal
favorites
shape will make no difference in the
Here and Now
22 years ago one ship could have stopped
this war before it started it began with
the 2015 interview with Chris Hardwick
in which Tarantino discussed his love of
Trek and his potential interest in
helming a movie Hardwick initially asked
the director about Star Wars but
Tarantino pivoted to say I would be more
inclined to do a Star Trek kind of thing
in September 2017 TMZ cornered Tarantino
at an airport and questioned whether
he'd actually direct such a project he
responded it would be worth having a
meeting by December of that year
deadline reported he was officially on
board and a writer's room was being
assembled to flesh out his pitch
things moved quickly and just a few
short weeks after the writer's room was
put together deadline reported that Mark
L Smith was announced as the writer of
the proposed film Smith's previous work
which included the Leonardo DiCaprio
drama the Revenant was a far cry from
the likes of previous track Riders
Roberto orsi and Alex kurtzman mostly
known for pinning popcorn Blockbusters
such as Transformers and Cowboys and
Aliens
in an interview with bulletproof
screenwriting Smith spoke about writing
the script with Tarantino and working
with J.J Abrams production company Bad
Robot he said they just called me it was
like the day later and said hey are you
up for it you want to go and if so then
you know Quentin wants to wants to hook
up so I said yeah sure he continued and
that was the first day I met Quentin in
the room and he's reading a scene that
he wrote I told him I was so mad I
didn't record it on my phone it would be
so valuable it was amazing
Smith gave a few hints about the still
unknown plot but mostly talked about his
enthusiasm about the project in a 2019
interview with Empire magazine Tarantino
himself noted that the script was done
as he weighed his options for his next
project saying there's a script that
exists for it now I need to weigh in on
it but I haven't been able to do that
yet
a year after the Project's announcement
the film's story was still a tightly
guarded secret nobody knew who would
start but the biggest question on
everybody's lips was whether Tarantino
himself would direct or just take
producer and story credits Paramount
must have been hopeful he would take the
helm but many outlets were skeptical
mostly because Tarantino wasn't known
for directing properties that he hadn't
created while he had directed a handful
of episodes for TV series including ER
and CSI his films were all Originals
with the exception of Jackie Brown which
was an adaptation of an Elmore Leonard
novel two years into development
Tarantino was still uncertain whether
he'd direct and the internet was a buzz
with rumors that he might be stepping
away deadline caught up with him and
asked him about the gossip he replied I
might be steering away from it but we'll
see I haven't completely decided or
talked to anyone involved nothing is
official in 2020 deadline reported
Tarantino had officially dropped out and
that if the movie were to be made he
wouldn't be sitting in the director's
chair
Tarantino's ninth film is director Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood hit theaters in
2019 and while that movie made quite a
splash his Star Trek proposal was still
a big topic speaking once again to
deadline the director revealed that his
track would be a balance between classic
Star Trek and his own Pulp Fiction
Tarantino also expressed his grievances
with Trek actors who had tried to Tamp
down the project he said their comments
weren't accurate because they weren't as
in the know as they claimed he named one
name specifically saying I get annoyed
at Simon Pegg he doesn't know anything
about what's going on and he keeps
making all these comments as if he knows
about stuff one of the comments he said
he's like well look it's not going to be
Pulp Fiction in space yes it is it's at
the very least unique in that regard
it's an interesting point
come on let's get into character
one actor who didn't seem to upset
Tarantino with his comments was Carl
Urban who played Leonard bones McCoy in
the three JJ Abrams produced Star Trek
films in a 2018 interview with
trekmovie.com the actor said he heard
the pitch and confirmed just how Wild it
was he also confirmed rumors that the
film would carry an R rating a first for
the franchise while some were concerned
this meant the film would be filled with
cursing and nudity Urban noted that it
was more about showcasing the true
horrors of space explaining you
shouldn't worry that it's going to be
full of obscenity and stuff he wants an
R rating to really make those beats of
consequence land it allows some breath
gives him some leeway to do that
according to deadline Tarantino himself
had asked the studio for an R rating
with Paramount and production partner
Bad Robot agreeing to it the director
later confirmed it in his 2019 deadline
interview saying if you've seen my nine
movies you kind of know my way is in our
R-rated way and a way that is without
certain restrictions Tarantino also said
the producer J.J Abrams was fully on
board and likened it to recent R-rated
Blockbusters saying Deadpool showed that
you can rethink these things do them in
a different way so really even before JJ
knew what the idea was his feeling was
if it wants to be an R rating fine if it
wants to be the Wild Bunch in space fine
without plot details many wondered if we
might see Chris Pine and Zachary Quinto
return especially given that the last
film in the series Star Trek Beyond was
considered a disappointment some
wondered if there might be an all-new
cast but Tarantino himself professed his
love for the Abrams cast and it soon
became clear that if the film were to
move forward that cast would return in
the 2017 deadline interview Tarantino
said that's why I actually really was so
taken with JJ Abrams first reboot and
how fantastic I thought Chris Pine
channeled William Shatner he's playing
the William Shatner version of Kirk and
he's doing a fantastic job at it I mean
perfect frankly and Zachary Quinto is
perfect as Spock in July 2018 Quinto
spoke to USA Today and confirmed his
involvement alongside the cast of the
previous three films I'm thrilled that
we might have the opportunity to work
with them and see what he would do with
us in this universe I've been a fan of
his for years and I'm real really
inspired by his originality
in his interview with bulletproof
screenwriter Mark L Smith explained how
the story of the movie involved a cool
gangster scene a deadline report also
mentioned that it might be a 1930s
gangster story which immediately got
fans speculating that it could be
inspired by or related to the classic
original series episode a piece of the
action the 1968 episode of the original
Star Trek series saw Kirk Spock and
Bones land on an alien planet with a
culture entirely based around
prohibition era Chicago the planet had
apparently been visited by another
Federation Starship in the days before
the prime directive and that ship
unwittingly contaminated the culture by
leaving behind a book titled Chicago
mobs of the 20s
though it may not be what many expected
a Star Trek gangster film certainly fit
Tarantino's description of something
we'd never seen in a big sci-fi movie
and there's no doubt it would have
offered him plenty of opportunities for
the kinds of crime stories he does best
following the release of Star Trek
Beyond Paramount was unsure of where to
take the franchise while audiences and
critics seem to like the film it
disappointed at the ticket counter
failing to live up to its predecessors
unsure of how to proceed Paramount was
thrilled to hear of Tarantino's interest
but the studio also decided not to put
all its eggs in one basket Spock actor
Zachary Quinto told deadline there were
as many as three different scripts in
development before the sequel was
officially given the green light I think
there's a couple of scripts you know
because there was a script being written
before Quentin Tarantino Quinto told ET
Canada that a sequel written by Simon
Pegg and Doug Jung was in the works
before Tarantino approached the studio
in 2017. Noah Holly of Fargo and Legion
was also reportedly developing a
screenplay that nearly went into
production screenwriters JD Payne and
Patrick McKay were also working on a
story that was dubbed Star Trek IV the
project was said to be directed by SJ
Clarkson and would have starred Chris
Hemsworth apparently entirely separate
from the version entering production in
2022 to be directed by Matt Jackman
Rod Roddenberry son of Star Trek Creator
Gene Roddenberry was pretty vocal about
his displeasure with Paramount bringing
in Tarantino to helm a new Trek film
Roddenberry serves as an executive
producer on the many new Star Trek
series including Discovery and strange
new worlds and he also acts as a steward
for the brand his father created in a
2021 interview with Forbes he said he's
a fan of Tarantino insisting that his
rejection of an R-rated Tarantino Trek
film had to do with the Integrity of the
franchise he said I struggle with the
Tarantino Star Trek film because the way
I'm pretty myopic with the way I see
Star Trek I grew up with fans saying how
Star Trek inspired them and gave them
hope for the future it's the optimism
and the messaging in there that make
Star Trek what it was with that in mind
Roddenberry didn't love the idea of Pulp
Fiction in space he continued I'll be
honest that doesn't work for me but he
is a fan and I think as a fan he
probably understands some degree that
Star Trek has to have some of this
hopeful optimistic messaging
many Trek fans were excited about the
prospect of Tarantino producing
something risky and daring one user on
trekmovie.com wrote Tarantino would
bring something fresh and the characters
would be vibrant and logical they added
that the director's involvement would
reinvigorate the film franchise others
weren't as happy about it another user
declared that under no circumstances
should this be allowed to happen on
Reddit user Dylan Vincent seemed to
agree with Rod Roddenberry saying this
is such a bad idea the original Spirit
of Star Trek it's no respect anymore
another redditor Concho bear offered
another Viewpoint saying I really hope
this happens this would be insane I love
Trek and Tarantino and they together
could be amazing with the idea
reportedly scrapped it seems the
naysayers got their way
as the rumor Mills swirled about
Tarantino's Star Trek project several
major Star Trek alumni expressed
interest in reprising their roles in an
interview with Reuters William Shatner
expressed his love for the director and
his passionate longing to return as
Captain Kirk he said Quentin Tarantino
said something in the paper that
somebody said to me that he loved me and
Quentin I love you if you're going to do
Star Trek hey 50 years later a few
pounds heavier come on not a problem I'd
like to do it George Takei who played
Sulu on the original series told Yahoo
entertainment of his interest but also
said it would all depend on the script
and it wasn't just original series stars
who spoke up Patrick Stewart who played
Captain Picard on Star Trek the Next
Generation made it clear that he'd love
to return if Tarantino was involved
telling The Hollywood Reporter one of my
dreams is to work with Tarantino I
admire his work so much and to be in a
Tarantino film would give me so much
satisfaction so if he is going to direct
something to do with Star Trek I would
embrace it
Picard carelessly risking the lives of
children the riots on earth a couple
years from now or whether Starfleet
foots the bill for O'Brien's therapy
sessions maybe it's time you do these
are the questionable things we ignore in
Star Trek from the earliest days of Star
Trek nearly every race we've met has
resembled ourselves Vulcans Klingons
romulans and even the Borg they're all
just like us except for the makeup and
Prosthetics sure some have forehead
ridges bumps and scales but only on rare
occasions have we seen genuinely unique
aliens some of the few exceptions to
this relative uniformity include the
shellyak in the Next Generation episode
The incense of command and species
Tennessee in Star Trek Discovery for a
fictional Universe where there is
seemingly no end to intelligent life
it's truly remarkable that nearly every
race our characters have encountered is
generally composed of carbon-based
humanoid bipeds beyond that almost all
of them can live in an oxygen atmosphere
Star Trek tried to explain this in the
season 7 episode of The Next Generation
titled the chase there we learned that
billions of years ago an ancient race of
humanoid aliens seated countless worlds
with their DNA guy fighting the
evolution of other species to their
shape and form it was a half-hearted
retcon that didn't make a lot of sense
and wasn't even necessary because
viewers also realized that producing a
weekly science fiction series like Star
Trek doesn't always Grant the luxury of
crafting expensive alien special effects
however it remains a bit difficult for
the audience to ignore the question of
why everyone looks so human
even non-trekies know that Vulcans are a
logical and emotionless race of people
Klingons are a race of Mighty Warriors
and romulans are scheming villains
dedicated fans know that the Ferengi are
greedy and motivated by profit while the
Borg only want to assimilate however in
the real world humans make up an
inherently diverse Society with a
variety of different attitudes interests
personalities and traditions yet on Star
Trek it often seems like every alien
race is described in surprisingly
singular terms of all the species we've
made contact with yours is the only one
we can't Define
sure later Star Trek shows tried to
expand the characterization of Vulcans
Klingons and romulans by introducing
factions among them with different
beliefs and goals still those retcons
don't change the fundamental depiction
of these groups as a whole beyond that
when Star Trek introduces a new planet
or race of people they are quick to
describe them in singular terms the real
world explanation is that it's a simple
shorthand to deliver the meat of the
story to audiences which explains why
viewers don't often question it
nevertheless for a series built off of
diversity most of its alien races are
anything but
according to Star Trek lore the United
Federation of planets was founded by
four alien races humans Vulcans
tellerites and andorians over the
centuries the organization has grown to
include more than 150 distinct planetary
governments and worlds despite this the
overwhelming majority of crew members we
see on Federation Starships Are human
sure every series has a token alien or
two on the bridge however while there
are ostensibly a handful of non-humans
serving on many Federation ships we
hardly ever see any of them and it's
almost always humans Milling around the
corridors it took until season 3 of
Discovery in fact for a series to Star
an alien Captain if the organization is
supposed to represent the entire
Federation we can't help but wonder why
their ships all seem to be so
human-centric once again this is almost
certainly a budgetary issue but when one
stops for even a moment to think about
it it makes you wonder if Starfleet has
an inherent terrestrial bias foreign
for a franchise that claims to be all
about diversity inclusion and equal
rights Star Trek has had some surprising
moments of sexism and misogyny in its
long history despite having a
high-ranking black woman serving on the
bridge controversial in its day the
original series too often made its women
out to be helpless and incompetent this
problem goes beyond the outmoded
attitudes of the 1960s that seeped into
the original series and continues with
the 1990s spin-offs even when the next
Generation tried to make a statement on
the objectification of women in the
episode the Perfect Mate it turned into
a message about respecting the
traditions of other cultures subtly
condoning the misogyny at the center of
the story Deep Space Nine did better as
characters are rarely defined solely by
their gender and female crew members
explore complex layered stories of their
own but Voyager was another matter
despite having the franchise's first
woman in the captain's chair the series
was Rife with subtle sexism in the
episode retrospect they went so far as
to victim blame seven of nine after an
apparent assault meanwhile many fans on
Reddit felt that neelix's relationship
with a much younger and naive Kess
bordered on abusive
Hollow decks were one of the first major
New pieces of tech introduced to
audiences in Star Trek the Next
Generation as a holographic simulator
room the hollow deck could create a
convincing life-like environment users
can visit anything from a 19th century
London Street to the valley of Chula on
Romulus employed for both Leisure and
training purposes it allowed the series
to explore strange new worlds within the
ship itself and offered up plenty of
opportunities for drama are you taking
life's death a little seriously after
all he was just honest with Garrett the
problem is nearly every time we see the
Holodeck it's malfunctioning whether
it's the result of a random power surge
radiation from a nearby star or a crew
member creating a super villain with a
set of cryptic instructions it seems as
if nothing ever goes right on the
Holodeck even the slightest malfunction
automatically shuts off the system's
safety protocols that prevent injury and
death taking the hollow deck from an
innocent and leisurely respite room to
an artificially intelligent kill box
Starfleet never seemed interested in
making it safer either
on Voyager and Deep Space Nine
malfunctions on holodecks and Hollow
Suites are still causing problems they
are easily manipulated too allowing
anyone with ill intent to turn them into
elaborate death traps considering how
often things go wrong on the Holodeck we
should be questioning why anyone in
Starfleet would ever set foot in one
even in the earliest days of Star Trek
the crew of the Enterprise goes back and
forth through time like they are headed
down the street for a cup of coffee in
the city on the edge of forever the crew
visits a planet with a living portal
that allows McCoy Kirk and Spock to
travel back to 1930s New York after a
mix-up and a fix-up they depart and do
nothing to warn other passing ships of
the portal they don't even contact
Starfleet to protect or research this
valuable Newfound Gateway time travel is
featured heavily in the movie Star Trek
4 the Voyage Home where it appears even
less consequential all it takes is some
mathematical calculations and a
slingshot around the Sun and blammo
they're back in 1986. it can't be that
simple and painless could it Star Trek
Picard uses this method again in the
series second season but at least that
is done to repair the timeline
eventually Starfleet wises up and
creates the temporal prime directive
however time travel continues to be
treated as if it were largely
unremarkable
time travel this is my first day on the
job as a Starfleet captain I swore I'd
never let myself get caught in one of
these God forsaken paradoxes even the
Advent of the Department of temporal
investigations doesn't seem to do much
to slow down the number of time travel
incidents we see in the franchise
like Transporters the universal
translator is an essential piece of Star
Trek technology that we are almost
required to accept without question
though it may not have been invented by
Star Trek the franchise certainly
popularized the concept of a device that
instantly translates all communication
unlike the telepathic field that
converts languages in Doctor Who the
universal translator is a technological
device curried by every crew member it's
also embedded in every ship's
communication system allowing characters
and the audience to understand each
other despite speaking their own native
alien languages however it's never made
clear how they work and the few times
they've delved into those details it
doesn't really add up is it a physical
Communicator with a speaker that
translates in real time does it mute the
person's voice do you hear them speaking
in their language with the translation
overlapping or do you see the person's
mouth moving out of sync in early
episodes It's shown as a handheld device
while one Deep Space Nine out of episode
sees Ferengi characters describe the
tech as small enough to be hidden deep
inside their ears and yet despite still
knowing very little about how the
universal translators work they've
continued to be a key element in a
number of stories every time the show
tries to deal with it it only creates
more questions believing us wishing
they'd hand wave it as vague science
because ultimately it's the kind of
questionable aspect of Star Trek that is
best left ignored
when Star Trek the Next Generation first
launched in 1987 it boasted several
notable differences from its 1960s
parent series instead of a young dashing
fist first Captain Kirk we meant the
Diplomatic contemplative and Stern
Captain Picard Not only was there a new
crew but there was a new starship too
the updated Enterprise D was bigger
faster and more powerful but it included
a surprising addition families and
children this new ship could also
separate in times of battle with the
saucer section which housed hundreds of
civilians including children of all ages
and an entire school system able to zip
off under its own power
more often than not the Enterprise D
found itself in conflicts with the
Klingons romulans or the Borg but never
bothered to get the saucer section to
Safety in fact during the show's entire
seven season run it only successfully
separates three times thankfully it does
separate in the film Generations when
the ship's warp core destroys the rest
of the vessel with so many civilians on
board it would seem that the captain
should immediately separate the ship and
get them to safety before entering a
potentially dangerous situation why
Picard doesn't do that is anyone's guess
Commander Shelby prepared to initiate
your plan to separate the saucer section
when we find the Borg
when it launched in 1966 the 1990s must
have seemed far enough out after all
radio is a dominant medium just decades
ago so they might not have suspected
television would last into the next
millennium let alone take their little
science fiction series along with it as
such the writers of Star Trek didn't
hesitate to establish a fictional
history of the rest of the 20th century
and beyond this included a global
conflict in the 1990s called the
Eugenics Wars during which the
genetically engineered Tyrant Khan
noonian Singh ruled more than half the
planet a third world war was said to
have taken place in the early part of
the 21st century while later Ceres
mentioned missions to Mars and civil
unrest across the planet in 2024 even
though some of that could still come to
pass much of the fictional history of
Star Trek no longer matches up with the
real world newer shows like Star Trek
Voyager and Star Trek Picard which see
characters travel back to our present
have tried glossing over those details
or retconning events unfortunately for
the series by but fortunately for us the
fact remains that Star Trek can no
longer reconcile the history of their
fictional Earth with our real one
many episodes of Star Trek have included
or been built around characters going
through traumatic events these shocking
incidents include Kirk being forced to
let the woman he loves die in city on
the edge of forever and Picard's
imprisonment by cardassians in chain of
command however in almost every instance
the Enterprises officers are back on
duty right away as if nothing happened
they are not given time to recover and
we rarely hear how they're dealing with
what they've been through the Next
Generation does dedicate an entire
episode to Picard's recovery from his
assimilation by the Borg and family but
he is still in command of the Enterprise
once he is deassimilated in fairness
much of this is due to the episodic
structure of the earlier shows which
largely avoided longer serialized arcs
however even on Deep Space Nine where
serialization is standard Chief O'Brien
is regularly put through the ringer he
is tortured by Kardashians virtually
imprisoned for two decades and regularly
suffers some of the worst incidents the
show presents yet each week is back on
duty as soon as he returns to the
station you'd think by the 24th century
Starfleet would have more enlightened
attitudes toward dealing with workplace
stress you'd think they'd mandate
recovery time or treatment to keep their
officers in Peak mental shape however it
seems like in the world of Star Trek you
are mostly expected to be back to work
immediately after undergoing severe
trauma besides you know the adage
Captain goes down with his ship
which episode of the original Star Trek
was so bad that Leonard Nimoy was still
embarrassed about it years after the
fact and why did one Walking Dead star
almost quit acting entirely keep
watching to find out
few people have been in more Star Trek
projects than Jonathan Frakes this means
that despite all the wonderful memories
as Will Riker Frakes also remembers a
whole lot of bad moments for instance
Frakes himself called the Next
Generation episode code of honor a
horrible racist episode and allegedly
tried to get it pulled from syndication
however the scenes he regrets the most
aren't in the Next Generation instead
they come in his one episode appearance
in Enterprise where he provided the
framing story for the series finale
These Are the Voyages
the problem Frakes feels that his
presence was a disservice to the regular
cast of the show as Riker permeates the
episode appearing at dramatic times that
should belong to other characters like
the traumatic death of Commander Tripp
Tucker even the last line of dialogue in
the entire series is spoken by Riker
rather than one of the show's regular
cast members computer
Frakes has called it an unpleasant
memory in 2011 he told fans at central
Canada Comic-Con they said it would be a
valentine to the fans but all it ended
up doing I think was hurting Scott
Bakula's feelings he was such a
gentleman about it and I said to Scott
this is weird for me to be on your show
I wasn't crazy about it bacula himself
has never spoken about the finale but
the tensions were clearly there as
writer producer Brandon Braga called it
the only time Scott Bakula was ever mean
to me
though Enterprise is often considered a
low part of Trek's history many fans
still have an affection for it and few
characters from the series get more love
than Tripp Tucker played by Connor
trineer but traneer wasn't happy with
his character's pointless death and his
biggest issue with it had nothing to do
with Riker looming in the background
instead it was just the disappointing
way Tripp died blowing himself up to
take out three randos As trineer Told
Trek today I've gotten out of much worse
scrapes than that
Malcolm McDowell played one of the most
important villains in Star Trek history
as Dr toli and Soren in Star Trek
generations he was the force that United
Jean-Luc Picard and James T Kirk he was
also the man who kinda killed Kirk using
a delayed response bridge collapse as it
turns out McDowell thought that was
pretty stupid in 2011 he told star
trek.com if you have this icon of
American television why the hell didn't
they give him a spectacular death why
did they give him such a really paltry
death me shooting the bridge out or some
BS whatever it was they should have sent
him off in a glorious fashion and they
didn't
the scene originally had sauron's shoot
Kirk in the back before reshoots
McDowell also found this disappointing
and he lamented that they couldn't
figure out a better death he told Metro
it was feeble I thought because I
thought he deserved better
William Shatner has spent decades as one
of the faces of Star Trek and when
you're the head honcho of the USS
Enterprise this comes with many great
moments but it also comes with many
deeply embarrassing ones some of these
were a product of the time period others
were a product of Shatner's own ego but
the scene he publicly regrets most is
his final scene when asked by crave
online whether he was satisfied with
Kirk's death in Star Trek generations
Shatner replied no no I would have done
something else according to Shatner the
suits at Paramount figured the Star Trek
franchise might make a lot more money if
they included the Next Generation cast
They also allegedly reasoned that there
wasn't much milk left in the original
series Cash Cow so it was a perfect time
for Kirk to meet Picard and they also
wanted to kill off Kirk in order to
raise the stakes and Signal a permanent
Changing of the Guard Shatner told
trackmovie.com that he was presented
with two options it was either I was
going to appear and die or they were
going to say he died so I chose the more
practical of the two between the
lackluster reviews and the pathetic
death Shatner wasn't happy he said I
wish that there had been more trumpets
for the death of the character
foreign
was there for many of Star Trek's
greatest moments it's easy to picture
him performing a Vulcan nerve painter
explaining how the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few but he was
also front and center for one of Trek's
worst hours Spock's brain an episode
that was deeply embarrassing for him
though it aired a half century ago
perhaps no episode has come to symbolize
Trek at its worst more than Spock's
brain the episode sees Spock's brain
surgically removed and kidnapped by an
alien species Balkan physiology lets
their bodies stay alive for 24 hours
without a brain so Kirk goes hunting for
it even for 60s sci-fi that was a bridge
too far in his autobiography I am Spock
Nimoy singled it out as a particularly
painful memory writing frankly during
the entire shooting of that episode I
was embarrassed a feeling that overcame
me many times during the final season of
Star Trek
though Deep Space Nine is considered the
gritty Star Trek it still had a fair
number of off-putting moments including
some from no-nonsense Commander Benjamin
Cisco when asked at a convention what
his least favorite scenes were Avery
Brooks said it was a toss-up between two
choices the first was move along home in
a scene that even the Deep Space Nine
documentary what we left behind called
out as the worst scene in the series
he knew right away that he'd never live
it down saying there's nothing wrong
with the melody it's the Hopscotch part
the second was apocalypse rising in
which he played a Klingon which involved
enough Prosthetics that it necessitated
a dentist appointment but while he
didn't want to do it Brooks had no
choice he said the resistance You
observe with Cisco playing a Klingon was
real Dr Julian Bashir initially received
some backlash from Deep Space Nine fans
he was seen by some as boring Brash and
worst of all kind of annoying but while
the producers had a plan to make him
more interesting they didn't run it by
actor Alexander sidig first the episode
Dr Bashir I presume reveals that Bashir
was genetically modified as a child
which made him much smarter but siddig
didn't learn about this plot development
until the day before shooting he was
upset that the producers wouldn't go
over a major character Arc with the
actor actually playing the character so
he staged his own personal protest he
told trekmovie.com I did it the only way
that an actor can I completely destroyed
the lines that they gave me regarding
the situation he tanked the storyline
putting no effort into it going so far
as to pin the lines up on set so he
could just read them instead of memorize
them it might have been Petty but it was
probably pretty satisfying nonetheless
new Star Trek characters were more
grounded than next Generations Dr
Beverly Crusher except of course that
one time she fell in love with a ghost
in a magic lamp subarosa is often listed
as one of the worst episodes of the next
generation an attempt at Gothic romance
in Space the story in somewhat reductive
terms involves Beverly falling in love
with a ghost inhabiting a lamp it's
worth mentioning that this lamp ghost
has also seduced several generations of
her family needless to say actress Gates
McFadden found the whole concept absurd
in 2012 she told the crowd at Austin
Comic-Con I was reading this going this
woman became a doctor and she's in love
with a lamp I Love Lamp
do you really love the lamp are you just
saying it because you saw it
I Love Lamp
Armand shimmerman is best known as Quark
on Deep Space Nine but years before DS9
was ever conceived he had a part as a
ferranki on the Next Generation not just
any Ferengi either but one of the first
ones ever put to screen and he regrets
every second of it the Ferengi were
introduced in the last outpost just a
few episodes into the new series The
Ferengi Were Meant To Be menacing
threatening and anything but funny
nonetheless they came across as comical
and the episode is held in low regard to
this day their credibility as villains
tanked and they were mostly comic relief
until Deep Space Nine shimmerman blamed
himself telling Gamespot no one Bears
the brunt of that mistake more than I do
so shimmerman approached Quark as an
attempt to salvage the Ferengi all of my
work on Deep Space Nine for the first
four seasons was me trying to eradicate
that original performance from
everyone's mind
one of the all-time great comedic
actresses Terry Garr has played in
Classics like Tootsie and Young
Frankenstein she also played Roberta
Lincoln in assignment Earth the season 2
finale of the original series it was one
of her first speaking parts and she
later credited it in her autobiography
with getting her real roles that doesn't
mean she liked it or even wants to talk
about it though Gene Roddenberry
intended assignment Earth to be a
backdoor pilot to a new series hedging
his bets in case Star Trek got canceled
ultimately Star Trek got a third season
and assignment Earth remained a
standalone episode but years later when
interviewed for starlog magazine gar
said I did that years ago and I mostly
deny I ever did it exactly why guard
disliked the experience so much as
unclear though producer Bob Justman said
in his book inside Star Trek that Gene
Roddenberry pushed to have gar wear a
shorter and more revealing skirt
whatever happened it was enough to sour
her on the whole franchise and fan base
she was glad assignment Earth never
launched saying otherwise all I would
get would be Star Trek questions for the
rest of my natural life and probably my
unnatural life you ever see those people
who are Star Trek fans the same people
who go to swap meets
you'd be forgiven for missing the fact
that Jeffrey Dean Morgan appeared as an
alien in the Enterprise episode
Carpenter Street as he was completely
buried in makeup and he hated the entire
experience in 2003 Morgan's career
wasn't doing so well and he needed work
so he took a role in Enterprise he
expected to do some line readings
instead he got four hours a day in a
makeup chair he told Entertainment
Weekly I remember them dripping poop on
my face and I had straw sticking out of
my nose I couldn't eat lunch I was
claustrophobic I'd go home in tears the
whole process was so miserable he almost
quit acting luckily he didn't and the
job helped him stay afloat until better
things came along don't threaten me with
a good time
Garrett Wang doesn't openly regret many
scenes he played as ends in Harry Kim
rather he regrets the scenes he didn't
get to play namely any as a senior
officer Wang still takes Umbridge with
the fact that Harry remained an Ensign
throughout Star Trek Voyager telling
star trek.com I mean come on people Kim
was probed beaten tortured and held the
distinction of being the first Voyager
crew member to die and come back to life
what more does a guy have to do to get
promoted to Lieutenant for frack's sake
Wang called writer producer Brandon
Braga during the fourth season to ask
why Harry hadn't been promoted he was
told quote well somebody's got to be the
ensign
getting shank to death by a secret
Klingon Sleeper Agent being cloned into
existence just so you can die after
giving up your brain tissue dying's
never been easy and it's even worse on a
Starship here are the most devastating
deaths in the Star Trek franchise in the
classic 1967 Star Trek episode the city
on the edge of forever the Enterprise
visits a deserted world where they
discover an ancient portal into the past
a sick Dr McCoy passes through it and
changes history so that the Enterprise
never existed forcing Kirk and Spock to
follow him through the portal to fix the
timeline finding themselves in the Great
Depression the Duos search for McCoy
leads them to a woman named Edith Keeler
who runs a homeless shelter
I find her most uncommon Mr Spock while
Spock tries to discover the event that
caused history to be altered Kirk gets
to know Keeler and the two start falling
in love when Spock learns that in order
to fix the timeline they must restore a
history where Edith Keeler died in a
fateful car accident Kirk is determined
to continue his relationship with her
though in the end it's Kirk who stops
McCoy from saving her devastated the
captain is forced to sacrifice the woman
he loves to save all of humanity a
powerful ending to what is often
considered the best Star Trek episode
ever Star Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan is
considered a classic for many reasons
including its brilliant villain its
dramatic Climax and of course the death
of Mr Spock after the release of Star
Trek the motion picture in 1979 actor
Leonard Nimoy made it clear to producers
that he wasn't enthusiastic about
returning to play Spock again but they
were able to get him back thanks to a
terrific script Wrath of Khan director
Nicholas Meyer said producer harv
Bennett lured him with the promise of a
terrific death scene which Shatner and
he played so touchingly in the film The
Enterprises engine is damaged while
locked in combat with Khan's Stone one
star Fleet ship the USS Reliant Spock
heads down to the reactor room to fix
the problem but to do so he must endure
a lethal dose of radiation his sacrifice
saves the ship and he delivers a final
emotional speech to Captain Kirk that
has gone down as one of the most iconic
in film history
just logical
thankfully Nimoy had a change of heart
during principal photography which led
to reshoots setting up his return in the
follow-up film but at the time his death
was a first for trekkies who were forced
like the helpless Captain Kirk to watch
a beloved and iconic character die
before their eyes introduced in the Star
Trek the Next generation's second season
episode The Emissary the half human half
Klingon klar was a special Federation
Emissary brought on board the Enterprise
during a crisis involving a derelict
Klingon ship a former lover of Klingon
security Chief Lieutenant Wharf the pair
rekindled their physical relationship
during the mission Wharf is left jilted
however when kalar refuses to commit to
him in a Klingon bonding ritual in the
fourth season episode reunion kailar
returns when the Klingon Chancellor Kim
Peck is on his deathbed and she doesn't
come alone with her is Alexander her son
sired by Wharf but after kailar gets too
close to uncovering the treachery of the
villainous Klingon duras she winds up on
the wrong side of his Blade with her
dying breath kailar leaves Alexander in
wharf's care Wharf gets his revenge on
Doros but Taylor's death marked a major
turning point in his story forever
defining his character it gave him a son
in Alexander who would go on to play a
substantial supporting role in the
series though not a major character the
young Bjorn officer and cincito Jackson
made an impression on audiences with her
wide-eyed optimism and Soulful
personality her first appearance came in
the fifth season of Star Trek the Next
Generation where she was caught up in a
cover-up at Starfleet Academy over the
death of a fellow Cadet she would make a
surprise return in season 7 where she
was assigned to the Enterprise and up
for a promotion the episode revolves
almost entirely around the lives of four
young officers aboard the Enterprise
during their crew evaluations but when a
cardassian double agent arrives looking
for safe passage back home jaxa is
recruited by Captain Picard to help
pretending to be a bajorn prisoner she
will make his trip more believable with
him posing as a returning Bounty Hunter
however at the climax of the episode the
plan to return jaxa to the Enterprise
fails and the young officer is killed by
a cardassian patrol it's a grim dark
ending to what was otherwise a
relatively lighthearted episode and a
devastating end to what was a promising
new character the first feature film
starring the cast of Star Trek the Next
Generation was designed to be a passing
of the Baton from the original Star Trek
crew Kirk Scotty and Chekhov all
appeared at the beginning of the film to
Christen the Enterprise B the first
Enterprise with a new crew but during
their first voyage disaster strikes won
a strange space anomaly called the Nexus
damages the ship taking Kirk with it
what if I told you I found a new truth
the Nexus
nearly 100 years later Captain Picard
and the USS Enterprise D are facing a
villain named Soren who is seeking to
enter the Nexus himself and threatens to
destroy a planet to do it when Picard is
drawn into the anomaly he finds none
other than his predecessor Captain Kirk
as he was when he was taken a century
earlier the two Enterprise captains
worked together to stop Soren but Kirk
is killed during the film's climax much
to the dismay of the fans while not the
most well-regarded Star Trek movie
receiving plenty of criticism from
audiences and critics alike it's hard to
deny the devastating impact Kirk's
passing had on the fandom killing off
the man who was arguably the biggest
star in Star Trek stunned audiences and
it was regretted almost instantly by
actor William Shatner who seemingly made
it his personal mission to return to the
role making her debut in the fourth
season of Star Trek Deep Space Nine
Torah Zeal is the half bajoran half
Kardashian daughter of the series main
villain gold ducat the product of an
affair while ducat was the prefect of
bonjour Zeal and her mother were sent to
a neutral planet after the cardassian
occupation came came to an end but their
transport ship the ravenock was lost
after an attack by the Breen years later
evidence of the ravenox crash site
surfaces so major Kira and ducat mount a
rescue mission and discover Zeal alive
fearing her existence might threaten his
power in the cardassian military ducat
plans to kill Zeal but is talked out of
it by Kira eventually Zeal forges a new
relationship with her father and comes
to live aboard the Deep Space Nine
station she forms a sisterly bond with
Kira and even a romantic relationship
with the enigmatic former spy Garrick
but when the imperialistic forces of the
Dominion take over the station Zeal
defies her father by helping the
resistance fight back during the
climactic moments when Starfleet retakes
the station ducat can't convince the all
to leave in a shocking final twist his
top Lieutenant Demar murders the All In
Cold Blood like Sito jaxa zial was an
upbeat optimistic character whose
presence added a warmth and earnestness
to the series not only did her death
devastate audiences it sent ducat into a
psychotic spiral ultimately breaking him
following the the sixth season of Star
Trek Deep Space Nine series Mainstay
Terry Farrell who played the science
officer Jadzia Dax was up for contract
renewal according to Farrell she was
told by producers to accept whatever
offer she was given because if she
wasn't on Deep Space Nine she would be
quote working at Kmart understandably
frustrated Farrell declined their offer
however rather than writing Dax out of
the series in a way that could allow for
future guest appearances The Producers
opted to kill the character off in a
devastating season finale most viewers
unaware of the behind the scenes drama
were taken by surprise when a possessed
ducat murders Dax while she visits a
bajorn shrine Dax had recently married
longtime fan favorite Wharf and the pair
were hoping for a baby the exit of one
of the series biggest characters in the
midst of such an emotional story was a
brutal Heartbreaker for fans who is this
person how did she get the symbiance to
wait in one other Dax in my life did she
always talk this much these are all very
good questions
thanks to the magic of Science Fiction
of course the trill symbiant within her
was given a new body and actress Nicole
de Boer replaced Farrell as the new
character esri though not exactly a
death per se the series finale of Deep
Space Nine did see the end of corporeal
existence for the show's longtime
Captain Benjamin Cisco having finally
accepted his role as the Emissary of the
prophets Cisco battles against their
greatest enemies the Paw rates meanwhile
ducat has been cast out by his own
people and Embraces the Paw rates as a
way of getting revenge on his Nemesis in
a final showdown in the bajorn fire
caves Cisco and ducat have it out once
and for all though Cisco and the
prophets Prevail the captain's physical
body is destroyed while the crew of Deep
Space Nine the bajorn people and his
wife and son all mourn his death it's
revealed that Cisco actually transcended
his physical existence he is now a
prophet himself it was the first time in
Star Trek history that a series ended
with the death of a major character
though actor Avery Brooks hasn't
performed on screen in over 20 years
Cisco is technically still still out
there somewhere and could theoretically
return the death of chief engineer
Charles Tripp Tucker in the final
Enterprise episode is considered
crushing by many trekkies but another
death of sorts can be seen as much more
devastating the season 3 episode
similitude saw Tripp critically injured
in the ship's resident doctor Cooks up
an unusual cure to save him using the
Genome of a rare species of larva they
create a clone of trips so they can
Harvest its brain tissue to save the
original given that the new being will
only have a lifespan of about two weeks
the plan is to let the Clone live out
its life and die naturally thereby
allaying most of their ethical concerns
but their convictions are tested when
the Clone grows from a child to an adult
in a matter of days and begins to form
friendships with the people aboard the
Enterprise the clone of trip falls in
love with to Paul and becomes a valued
member of the crew eventually Sim as he
becomes known is forced to confront the
nature of his existence while everyone
around him must wrestle with the
emotional consequences of their actions
though a short-lived clone instead of a
main character the death of sim was
still heartbreaking and possessed the
emotional weight lacking from Tripp's
actual death the Star Trek franchise was
rebooted in 2009 by JJ Abrams and became
the same fast-paced roller coaster that
had made the director famous but if
there's one thing Abrams loves more than
lens flares it's tugging at an
audience's heartstrings with devastating
emotional moments Star Trek begins
aboard the Federation Starship USS
Kelvin as it encounters a mysterious
spatial anomaly when an enormous Romulan
Starship emerges from it and kills his
captain the first officer George Kirk
played by then unknown Chris Hemsworth
takes command he attempts to fight off
the enemy ship but the battle goes badly
Kirk orders all hands to abandon ship
including his wife going into labor in
sickbay having lost their autopilot he
stays behind to Pilot the Kelvin setting
a collision course with the Romulan
vessel to save the fleeing crew the last
man on the bridge Kirk calls his wife
aboard a shuttle and delivers an
emotional goodbye the husband and wife
named their son James Tiberius Kirk just
as the two ships Collide despite only
knowing the Elder Kirk for a matter of
moments his death is a devastating gut
punch for audiences to start the film
this next entry on our list is the death
of an already deceased character as the
entire first season of Star Trek Picard
had the former Enterprise Captain
mourning the loss of his old friend
Commander Data who had been killed in an
act of self-sacrifice in the 2002 film
Star Trek Nemesis if you had data's
neural net perfecting a flesh and blood
host body would be relatively simple it
is neurons down
thanks again to the magic of Science
Fiction data makes a return in the
Picard series though when data
surprisingly asks Picard to end his life
to give his existence meaning the latter
agrees the two share a quiet moment and
data sips a glass of wine before laying
down and passing away it's perhaps one
of the most emotionally heart-rending
deaths in the franchise while data had
technically died once before this more
conclusive ending is far more
devastating we're losing him again after
a nearly 20-year absence a holdover from
Star Trek Voyager the character icheb
made a surprise appearance in a
flashback during the Star Trek Picard
episode Stardust City rag but the
ex-borg's return was short-lived as it
was revealed that it was his death that
motivated seven of nines Vendetta
against the ruthless criminal
businesswoman bajazzle eacheb was found
aboard a damaged Borg vessel with
several other Borg children they were
eventually taken aboard the Voyager and
disconnected from the collective just
like seven of nine though the other
children were returned to their people
each app's parents had bred him as a
living weapon against the Borg he would
thus remain on Voyager returned with
them to Earth and later joined Starfleet
but in Stardust City rag were shown his
grisly end e-cheb is abducted and ripped
apart by bajazzle so she could Harvest
his parts to sell after his demise seven
would never be the same and neither
would audiences with many feeling that
echeb's graphic death scene had gone too
far Star Trek Discovery the first Star
Trek series in more than a decade was a
new beginning for the franchise it set
itself apart in a number of ways from
its predecessors from its darker tone to
its big budget action Commander Paul
stamets and chief medical officer Hugh
colber played by Anthony Rapp and Wilson
Cruz respectively were the first gay
crew members in Star Trek history living
together on the ship as a committed
couple that's why it came as such a
shock when in the first season Cobra was
brutally murdered after crewmate Ash
Tyler determines he's suffering from
some kind of traumatic repressed memory
he goes to colber for help the chief
medical officer discovers that Tyler
isn't human at all and has been
surgically implanted with a Starfleet
officer's personality on top of his real
identity that of a vicious Klingon
massage I evoke who promptly breaks
Cobra's neck while some critics knocked
the death of Cobra as an example of the
unfortunate Trope of killing off gay
characters it's hard to argue that it
was anything less than one of The
Season's most devastating moments Star
Trek Discovery brought Culper back in
season two and he since followed the
crew of Discovery into the 32nd Century
where he and stamets remain a happy
couple
[Music]